Five thing too.
Hello Billy.
We're alive.
Yo Joe,
what's going on buddy?
How you doing?
I watch a new documentary this morning in the gym.
Loved it.
It was fucking great.
It's crazy.
I love your use of little kids.
I don't want to give away too much of it.
Uh,
but it's about the steroid scandal involving baseball and Alex Rodriguez.
But what was the choice to use little kids to play a rod and all the other key
principles involved in the scandal?
Like till the platelet.
Use a little actors.
What kits?
Oh come on Fella.
You're just hided God it was pretty sober.
The Gym.
Yeah.
Um,
so you,
you now know this story cause you've seen the doc and if people remember the
biogenesis steroid scandal,
if not the movie I think recaps it pretty pretty well.
But the thing that struck me is it like all these guys acted like children.
They really did.
And,
and to boot.
So,
you know,
we've done some,
some sports docs in the past.
We did,
you know,
some of the ESPN 30 for 30 is like the U.
And,
um,
when you do a sports doc,
I mean I don't want to say it's,
it's easy cause it's,
you know,
making documentaries is a challenge.
But sports docs are pretty like paint by numbers.
It's like you interview some players,
interview some coaches and journalists,
they mentioned a bunch of games and you show a bunch of game footage.
You know,
like it's a pretty straightforward process with this one.
It's not about baseball,
it's baseball adjacent I guess.
But like it's about shit that went down in nightclubs,
in shady clinics with fake doctor's hotel rooms,
bars,
locker rooms.
So you got a bunch of guys talking heads and your documentary,
but then you got,
you got nothing just cut to you.
You've got no B roll.
So I'm like,
we're going to need to shoot recreates,
you know,
recreation's here,
which is,
which is to me,
I,
I dunno,
it's like when you're doing nonfiction filmmaking,
it's fake shit.
We need when you film recreation.
So it's like,
I'm like,
how do we do this in a creative way that that's consistent with the tone of the
movie,
which was always called screw ball.
Meaning it was always like a farce,
you know,
like a Carl Hiaasen or Elmore Leonard Cohen,
brothers s sort of Florida fuckery farce.
And so we just wanted to keep in that,
in that mode.
So I'm watching the characters.
So we got Tony Bosch,
uh,
who is the fake doctor and Porter Fisher who was the whistle blower who stole
the medical records and,
and started this whole thing.
They were then stolen from him and then sold to not the highest bidder but any
bitter and every bitter they were sold to.
And they're talking and I'm noticing that they had like a very similar
storytelling style.
Like for example,
guys will be like,
so I walked into his office and I say,
I want my money and he says,
I don't have your money.
And I said,
well,
you better get my money.
And he said,
what are you going to do about it?
And I,
I'm going to break your net.
And I'm like,
Oh shit,
they're so vivid.
And in the moment and,
and,
and talking dialogue.
So we could trunk history this,
right?
We can,
we can edit together the doc.
And then have the actors lip sinking,
the actual interview dialogue and all the actors will be eight years old.
And I don't know,
like I,
I've always wanted to do it like way back a Spike Jones,
1997 biggy video.
Sky's the limit.
Biggie adjustment murdered.
He was faced with this challenge of producing a posthumous video.
And so spike Jones was like,
okay,
we'll just do a straight up classic bad boy records Circa [inaudible] 97 music
video cars,
Versace,
wardrobe girls,
Manchin,
hot tub,
but they'll all be eight years old.
You got baby biggie,
maybe puffy because baby Busta rhymes baby.
A little kid.
Yeah,
it's brilliant.
And so I was like,
what a great diva that was always kicking around since,
since 97 and then I saw this off Broadway musical about 10 tennis years ago
called a very merry on [inaudible].
Let me try that one more time.
A very merry unauthorized children's Scientology pageant.
I don't ask me to say it again.
I can't say it again.
Um,
so it's this,
it's this wild musical,
like very Bowie esque score written by a couple of Yalies.
Like,
it's like it's a,
it's a Christmas pageant performed by elementary school kids,
but instead of the story of Jesus,
it's the story of l Ron Hubbard all with like in like a school play with like,
you know,
paper Mushy,
like sets and,
and,
and construction paper costumes and props.
And I wanted to,
I got together with one of the composers,
I had said,
listen,
I'd like to get the rights to your musical and make a Scientology documentary
using the kids and the musical as a framing device because in those days,
no one was making,
everybody makes Scientology documentaries in those days,
nobody was doing it particularly because like the church is so litigious and so
they had kind of left this musical alone.
So I thought like that might be a cool buffer.
Like maybe if I make a documentary,
it's a little light,
you know,
and it's like this children's musical,
but we intercut it with real,
real documentary investigation interviews and um,
that maybe we'll kind of get away with it.
Nobody wanted to make that movie to me.
Nobody,
I mean,
doors are closing before I even knocked out,
like got to them.
Um,
and I kind of filed again filed that idea away in the back of my head.
And then,
um,
a couple years ago there was that funny viral video of like,
it was like a scar face school play.
I don't know if it was like a bunch of little kids doing scarfaces like an
elementary school play.
And I was like,
this is such a,
it's such a great device and the problem is you need to find something that it
works for.
Like,
like cocaine,
cal babies would not have been appropriate,
for example,
of much eight year old kids running around.
It's not Bugsy Malone,
you know?
So,
um,
it just like,
it just like kind of the stars align.
We just like,
I was like,
this is,
this is going to work here.
I think it works.
It works great.
And it's such a crazy story and the fat,
well,
I don't want to give too much of it away because I really want people to watch
it because I mean I've,
I've talked about cocaine cowboys probably a hundred times in this podcast.
It's one of my all time favorite pod.
Thank you.
Excuse me all time.
Favorite documentaries.
But this is,
this is a story that almost writes itself.
It's so bonkers that,
and the fact that it all could have been avoided if one guy just paid another
guy or just didn't try to rip them off like four grand.
Yeah.
Like nothing.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's fucking crazy.
And the guy,
what a bizarro personality he was who just Tan every day and hang out at this
doctor's office in the waiting room telling everybody how great it was.
Like the whole thing is so strange.
Like that's,
everybody remembers it as like the a rod or a roid scandal,
you know?
And,
and the truth of the matter is it,
Alex Rodriguez was collateral damage in this whole thing.
It was not about him.
Don't tell Alex that,
but it's not about him.
You know,
it's it,
it was really the highest,
the career of the highest paid baseball player of all time effectively ended
over a $4,000 debt between this cocaine addicted fake doctor and his fake tan
addicted steroid patient.
And it's like,
that's what I said,
it's like a Florida fuckery stories straight up.
It just like this classic only in Miami,
absurd farce.
And if that's what you specialize in,
special as it Florida fuckery,
I go to your Twitter feed all the time for a current Florida fucker.
It's just,
it's,
yeah,
it's distilled.
It's just like,
it's pure.
It's 100% Florida fuckery is just,
it's,
and that's what this story is to me.
Cause like Miami is just,
well they say the great thing about Miami is it's so close to the United States,
but like,
it's also like,
it's a narrow,
because Casa Blanca,
like just people kind of flee to Miami from like all over the country and all
over the world,
usually leaving some kind of criminality in their wake and you know,
come here and kind of there and reinvent themselves.
You know,
like it's just,
and then you have all of these criminals there who then kind of baking in the
sun,
you know,
in this kind of multicultural fucking [inaudible],
that we have.
And then they just like,
and then they start putting their,
their minds together and brainstorming and they hatch just the most inane
schemes and scams.
Like that's our primary export from Miami is just schemes and scams.
Well,
it's just so amazing that it's still a cocaine culture too.
After all these years,
it's still has a giant cocaine engine pumping out all this chaos.
We don't have any indigenous industry.
I mean there's no factory where everybody goes to work and then 30 years later
it gets a watch.
There's no,
there's no business there.
It's Carl Hiaasen says,
all we produce in Florida is oranges and machine guns.
We don't,
we don't make anything that we sell the dream.
We sell the sunshine.
You know,
it's lies that came true,
you know,
and so,
and even more frightening is the Miami of today is the America of tomorrow.
So it's like there's a lot of lessons to be gleaned from down there,
but it's basically at this point,
uh,
money,
real estate hustle at a money laundering capital.
So it's really no different than it ever was.
Everybody likes to tell me how it's changed.
It's grown.
I'm like,
just because you've built a bunch of shit doesn't mean we've grown.
And Miami is just like,
Niamey is one of the youngest cities in the country.
In your parlance,
it would be about one person old or one and a half.
People that go like one and a half.
People that go,
you know,
like
we're the,
we're one of the youngest cities,
um,
barely a hundred,
just over a hundred.
You know,
correct me if I'm wrong cause I've said this before,
but isn't there more banks per capita in Miami than anywhere else?
Well,
certainly there certainly was,
um,
before the,
you know,
the,
uh,
the great recession when a lot of them started shutting down,
but most of them have rebounded.
Uh,
one of the clever things some of the real estate developers did was they opened
their own bank,
literally their own bank.
They had a bank where the entire board of the bank were all real estate
developers and over 90% of the loans the bank made was insider loans just to the
board.
And then of course they went belly up in the great recession.
And what happened?
We bailed them out.
It was all their own shit failed out real estate salesman,
real estates who loaned themselves money that is wound up being backed
ultimately by us.
By the taxpayer.
Yeah,
I mean that's the old,
remember that.
I mean you hear that line all the time now that like,
you know,
um,
the people used to rob the bank from the outside in.
Now it's now it's from the inside out.
But no,
none could be truer than,
than,
than that story.
And that's a Miami story.
And when the great recession happened,
the see had to open an office in Florida because we had more bank closures than
any other state in the union cause we were like,
you could go down there.
I mean you could buy a fucking mortgage for your dog at a drive through in
Miami,
in the,
in like the,
the late nineties,
early aughts.
And,
um,
I remember interviewing a guy,
we were doing,
working on a project called Ponzi state,
uh,
about the state of Florida as like a,
a case study in the great recession years ago.
He never finished it unfortunately,
but we're interviewing this guy and he says,
um,
you know,
we were,
and this is pre like big short like this before anybody sort of knew a lot about
this.
And he said we were down here in Miami setting fires and Wall Street was trying
to read our smoke signals.
That's why I say like the Miami of today is the America of tomorrow.
It's every time I go there I always go,
I forgot how fucking crazy this way so you really should have to have a
passport.
I love it.
I really do love it.
It's a crazy place to do stand up.
You know I did this job cause I was doing a Netflix special and I was doing it a
couple months after I did this Gig in Miami and so I was using those yonder
bags.
You know what those are
what people have to put their cell phone into this magnetic bag.
You keep the phone but you hold the phone in if you want to use it.
You just have to step outside of the,
opened up the bag and they give you your phone in every other city.
It made for a better show because people just sat down and watched the show in
Miami.
It made for literally 40% of the crowd at any given time was getting up and
going to the back and using their phone and coming back in.
They were just constantly moving around and presume what was to use their phone.
They might be a bit powdering their noses,
they might've been,
but it was the,
you know there was,
because I had done gigs before that where they didn't have the yonder bags and
this wasn't the problem but in Miami everybody needed to use their phones.
They just kept getting up and coming back and it was just chaos.
Well it's also a selfish town.
Like it's basically a town,
a town of assholes really.
And,
and so like I always say that,
I mean it,
it reflects in everything that we do in the way that we behave certainly in the
way that we drive.
Like believe it or not,
like people are so much more chill and calm here in traffic in La.
I swear to God and La was famous for like road rage,
like Ellie,
like
created,
invented road rage.
But like Miami is such a crazy,
angry,
weird place cause it's like when push comes to shove,
we're in Miami,
chill the fuck out.
Like it's,
it's all good.
It's a beautiful place and it's a shared experience.
The traffic sucks for all of us.
Just chill out and use your turn signal for crying out loud and just,
but that's why they,
I say that's why they call it Miami.
It's not an hour and or your Emmy,
it's my fucking Amie and stay out of my fucking Amie.
It's just,
I don't usually seem to love it.
You seem to thrive.
Yeah.
I can't really function anywhere else.
Uh,
that doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's,
and it's so frustrating to,
I was,
you know,
I'm a native Floridian and a lifelong Miami and I,
for a while I was,
I was pretty determined to like leave behind a better Florida than the one I
was.
I was born in
fail.
They fail.
The publisher is like,
so inexorably connected to cocaine.
Um,
one of my best friends,
Steve Graham,
was an ophthalmologist.
He did his residency in Miami.
So he did his residency in emergency rooms in Miami and he was there in the 80s
during like the height basically during when cocaine cowboys takes place and he
saw everything.
He mean he had all these pictures of bullet holes and skull fragments and people
with light bulbs stuffed up their asses and he said it every day was just
fucking chaos.
So we call it Miami idea.
Everywhere else the light bulb goes off over your head and Miami we shove it
right up our asses.
I said they had a pool light bulb out of a guy's ass in one of those ones that
look like a Christmas tree.
Those curly ones,
this guy stuck a light bulb off his ass and it broke in his ass.
At least he was concerned about the environment.
That's like one of those environmentally like sound like good,
no environmentally sound times and that they were just thicker glass.
Felt like he could get it in his ass better.
Well that was the error to cut your teeth if you were a cop or a lawyer or a
journalist or an er doctor.
I remember talking to any Er doctor once,
he tells me a story,
1980,
shortly after the Mariel boatlift started,
which I think everybody's kind of pop culture frame of reference for the Mariel
boatlift as Scarface.
Tony Montana was a Mary Alito that's at the beginning of the movie when,
you know,
Castro is ranting and raving that he's flushing the toilets of Cuba onto the
United States,
specifically to Miami.
And um,
so he was working at the,
uh,
the trauma center at Jackson Memorial,
our emergency room at in Miami.
And he said he got a Mariel refugee.
These guys would stand at the beach.
They would,
um,
it looked like Havana in south beach.
You know,
like there's that like coral sea wall and it's just like,
it had a really Havana vibe.
So they would go,
they would chill mostly at these flop houses,
south of fifth street in Miami Beach,
where like the cops would literally just,
they would be leaving after a stabbing at one of these places and they'd be
three blocks away.
They get a call to go back because now there was a shooting or something else.
They would be going there like a all around the clock and so,
and they would just get in gunfights like literally would just be like they,
someone would cheat it dominoes and they would just pull out a gun and one guy
would shoot the other guy.
And so he hasn't,
Mariel refugee who comes in to the emergency room with a gunshot wound and he
knew Spanish,
he was bilingual.
He said to the guy,
said,
you're really lucky because if this bullet had hit,
you know,
few centimeters or whatever,
this way you would've died immediately.
You would have bled out right there on the scene.
Died instantly and guide splits.
A few days later,
another Mariel refugee comes in with a gunshot wound in exactly the same spot
where he had told the other guy that if he got hit there,
he would have died,
could never prove it,
never was able to trace it back.
But he was pretty well convinced that it was a revenge shooting or the other
shooting and the guy knew exactly where to shoot him and kill him because the
doctor had told them where to do that.
But that was like every day in Miami.
The lady who cuts my hair for Christ sake,
she said,
Billy,
I was so naive in those days,
you know,
you,
she's,
I cut people's hair.
You know,
they come over to kiss her goodbye and put a tip in her,
in her pocket,
you know,
and she'd go home,
turn her pockets inside out,
have our little crumbled bills and everything.
And one day she finds a little Baggie of white powder that someone that one of
her clients had slipped into her pocket as a tip.
And she said to her girlfriend,
she's,
what?
What the hell is this?
And our friend said,
oh shit,
that's worth more than gold.
That's the best tip you got.
You got all day,
that little Baggie.
But that was just like the culture.
And it's,
and it's,
I mean,
it's not that,
it's not anywhere else.
Imagine that.
And like in Nebraska,
someone Tebah new and cocaine,
people would be like,
what?
What the,
what the fuck are you doing?
Listen,
it's just like,
like I said,
it's like America's Casa Blanca.
It's no place like it.
It's such a strange place.
Strange.
Everything is for sale still nothing,
you know.
And like I said,
we are about a person old.
That's how far back Miami goes.
I was watching a video about um,
the culture of renting supercars to people so that they can pretend that it's
their car.
Huge in Miami.
Yeah.
We got all these brickle brickle least a thousand years,
you know,
driving their rented fucking lamb bows and blowing the engines out on south
beach cause they don't know how to drive them.
They just getting towed down the street is just listen,
it's a fake it till you make it kind of town and there's nothing really to make
there.
You can't really,
other than a real estate hustle,
money laundering,
drugs,
politics,
being a crop politician,
there's really no other way to make it as not a real industry.
No,
not at all.
There's a lot of professional fighters come out of Miami,
that whole area,
coconut grove and a lot of aggression,
a lot of poverty.
It's a,
it's a third world economy down there.
The disparity between the haves and the have nots.
The income gap is widest and getting wider in Miami Dade county than just about
any city in the country or any,
any metropolitan area in the country.
So,
and that's why I said the Miami,
if today is the America of tomorrow,
if you want to know what challenges we'll face as a nation or calamities will
befall us in the years to come,
you need only look at,
at Miami TD Allman called it the canary in the coal mine,
the bellwether.
And so,
you know when,
when,
when the election was playing out the cycle in 2016 I was like,
it all my friends are just like this,
can,
this Trump thing can't happen.
I was like,
hang on,
I'll say Florida elected and in fact reelected Rick Scott to be governor.
He is the biggest medicare fraudster in the history of the United States.
Everybody knows it.
Everybody is aware of it.
It's very well publicized.
We've,
we reelected him,
okay.
We,
we,
we elected him twice as the top fucking executive in our state.
Like,
what makes you think that the United States of America wouldn't do that?
And I know it's fair to say like,
you know,
if you're going to be the governor of the state,
you should know a little something about the largest industry in the state.
Like you're going to be the governor of Michigan,
you should have some familiarity with the automobile industry in manufacturing
and in Florida.
If you're going to be the governor,
arguably you should know something about our biggest industry,
which has medicare fraud basically.
I mean,
you could argue that he's the most qualified man for the job.
Oh yeah.
We got like Medicare fraud is,
has,
is one of the largest industries,
has been for decades.
I mean we have billions and billions of dollars in fraud that just comes out it.
So they run it.
So you'll go into like little Havana Hialeah,
for example,
in a municipality and in Miami Dade,
and there'll be a little Alita sitting behind a desk,
half asleep,
and she'll be surrounded in this tiny little one room office by little
mailboxes,
you know,
like po boxes and a mail man comes in every day and just puts checks in the
boxes and they're like,
in some cases they've stolen,
um,
uh,
social security numbers and,
and you know,
uh,
stolen identities basically.
And some cases they're just old people who aren't aware that their mail is being
forwarded to this location.
And they've just got the,
I think Miami for awhile we had more medicare payments for HIV and AIDS
medication than every other part of the country combined.
And it's all just old people.
So it's like,
you'd have to assume that 100% of our elderly population suffered from HIV had
HIV were HIV positive.
I mean,
fucking impossible.
You had female patients getting penis pumps that were paid for by,
I don't even know that Medicare covered that.
I gotta look into that.
But I know that was a thing.
Well,
thanks Obama.
You watched the oxycontin express just now,
but that's all about how they would have the pain management centers and they
were connected to the pharmacies.
You'd go to the doctor,
hey my back hurts you.
Well you need this go right next door and you score it.
All they would describe was oxys and sometimes it wasn't even next door.
Sometimes he was like,
go to that window.
Yeah,
right next door.
They say she'll show the doctor your x-ray.
You'd have to get your x ray done somewhere else cause they weren't doing it.
So in hand,
the doctor,
your ray,
he look at it go,
oh shit.
It was upside down.
He wouldn't,
he wouldn't even give me like,
Oh yeah,
oh shit,
you know what you need,
go to that window over there and fill this prescription.
And we had more pill mills.
They called them in Broward County,
which is the county just north of Miami Dade.
Then we had McDonald's locations and there was literally like the Appalachian
trail.
They were coming down,
they were stocking up on oxy and we were fueling a death epidemic like in,
in Kentucky.
And when they're pulling over more cars with Florida plates,
then instate plates up there because Floridians were like,
well shit,
we can't let them have all the action will drive up and we'll export the shit.
And at the peak of the pill mill epidemic,
the oxy epidemic in Florida,
seven people a day were dying men,
women and children.
And,
and we subsist from hustle,
the hustle.
You wonder why didn't the government cracked down on that shit?
Why didn't they regulate it?
Well,
first our governor and we di we deal with this and screw ball is the biggest
medicare fraudster in the history of the country.
So he wasn't exactly shall we say,
vigilant or interested in cracking down on medical related fraud away with it.
Magic Maga,
Maga magic I guess.
I mean,
listen,
he,
he got,
he pled the Fifth Amendment like 75 times in the videotaped deposition that was
used in a campaign ad against him.
And Florida was like,
we're good,
we're good with that.
And he just,
I listen white Richmond kind of walk between the raindrops in this country,
you know,
it's just uh,
well sort of,
they got craft for getting a hand job.
That was Florida too.
So stupid.
It's crazy
stupid.
It's cool what we were talking about it like how does he not have a guy who you
get him jerked off?
Like there's probably a lot of gals out there that would like to make some
money.
You don't,
you don't have to go to a massage parlor.
The biggest bummer of it is,
is now my massage parlors closed down.
That's the problem.
Where do I go now?
It's the crop.
We were broke.
Guys go,
well the fact that they were filming you too,
like the whole thing,
it's so strange.
And if there was human trafficking going on,
there were cops chilling there for like six months and some ongoing
investigation.
Can you save these poor victims?
But human trafficking has become like this keyword and it's like this new sort
of like fearmongering kind of a term to get everybody all up in arms and now
they're kind of backtracking on that.
They're like,
well,
maybe it wasn't exactly redrafting.
Maybe it was just more of prostitution reason why he was a horrible person
because he was contributing to these people that were essentially being sold for
sex slavery.
Turns out that might have been a bit overblown,
no pun intended,
of block overblown.
But of course that's kind of how they have to sell it,
Ryan.
Otherwise people are like,
why are you wasting all this money on hand jobs?
No one cares why?
Because solving real crime is hard and dangerous and dangerous.
Okay.
So you can go and pick somebody up for marijuana or getting a hand job or
whatever and you can look like you're,
you're being proactive but solving a murder.
So that's hard,
man.
That's hard work.
Hard,
dangerous.
And you know,
if you go to a weird little Asian massage place and guys are coming out smiling
like,
hmm,
it's a,
you can start there.
Yeah.
You know,
talking about low hanging fruit,
real offense to crafts,
that's probably older fellow.
There was a,
a weird law in Hawaii where they were letting cops actually have sex with
prostitutes,
like to prove that they were prostitutes.
I think nearly half the states in the union have a law that allow police
officers to have sex with people in custody.
Why?
Yeah.
Really?
I can't make it.
How did he make this shit up?
That's,
and they're saying,
oh,
well it was consensual becomes that consensual.
They're in fucking handcuffs.
So to mean it's consensual.
Like what?
That's human trafficking.
If you asked me,
I mean,
well,
yeah,
obviously they're going to try to make deals.
Hey,
I'll suck your deck if you'd get me out of here.
How's that?
How's that consensual?
How's that legal?
It's crazy.
Is the ultimate,
I mean,
he talked about people holding power over people.
The kit,
ultimate coerced consent.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean that is,
that is more than an employer doing that to an employee.
I mean,
you're literally dangling there.
Freedom.
Talk about an abuse of power.
Seriously,
I just look,
I have all daughters.
I'm,
I'm not,
I don't want anybody's daughter to be a prostitute,
but I'm also 100% in favor of people being able to do whatever the fuck they
want.
And if someone's in a weird stage in their life where they'd rather jerk guys
off,
then work at Denny's,
like who is anybody to stop them from doing that?
The only problem is the social stigma that's attached to it.
The actual act itself is,
it's beneficial though.
The person gets something out of it,
you know?
I mean there's,
it's w p some people have a really hard time getting someone to have sex with
them.
You know,
it's,
I don't see it that it's just a crazy thing that we regulate something that mean
George Carlin had a great bit about it as the only thing where it's illegal to
do,
to make someone pay for it.
But it's fine if it's free.
I get literally doesn't make sense.
There's nothing wrong with sex,
but there's something wrong with people paying for it
and it's fine if you pay for it and then video tape it for distribution.
Cause then that's,
yeah,
I don't really,
first of all it's a contract between two consenting adults.
If we,
if we're talking about small government deregulation,
let's allow two consenting adults to engage in a contractual relationships,
offer acceptance consideration.
As with anything else,
a stigma.
As you mentioned,
a lot of that is part and parcel of the prohibition.
The illegality of it is what brings the seediness.
It's what brings the danger that it,
because it's forced underground,
uh,
you,
you introduce all of these elements that don't have to be there.
They can take place in clean environments.
They can take place instead of in the black market and underground.
It could take place in a where you can protect all the participants involved and
it,
but it's been true of liquor.
It's been true of marijuana.
It's been true of,
uh,
prostitution,
which they call for a reason,
the oldest profession.
Um,
the second we introduce the prohibition a creates a level of,
of danger and a threat to society that wouldn't exist.
If you're like,
well,
wait,
what if you just let me smoke this?
What if you just let me drink this because I'm an adult making a responsible
decision for myself.
What if you just let me engage in sexual activity with this person who is
perfectly willing to do it in exchange for some renumeration?
What the why should anybody give a shit about so pure tax.
It's so archaic.
It's such a dumb,
proven bad idea.
It's,
I mean,
it's been proven for decade upon decade.
Oh,
you go all the way back to the alcohol prohibition to what's going on right now
with the cartels.
I mean,
what,
how much would it fix if they made all drugs legal?
How much would it fix?
I mean we,
we'd have a real problem in the beginning with access where people would,
there would be so much more access.
You'd probably,
you know,
we,
you would lose people.
People would die and high profile overdose cases and people would try to make a
deal out of it.
You don't think that cocaine was legal everywhere that meth people can get the
drugs.
Right,
but it's not that easy for a person.
Like,
if you don't know anybody who's a criminal,
like say if you want to buy meth now,
I don't know where to buy math.
I just,
I know a few Walmarts in Florida,
they make it in the bathroom that you do with that.
Again,
that is Florida.
It's a different animal.
But like right now in America,
I mean,
I maybe could drum up some meth and a few days if I started asking,
but,
uh,
you know,
I would not have any idea who was an informant and who's going to rat me out.
But I think the stats show in states where marijuana has become legal,
you don't see significant spikes in usage.
Parents,
it's minimal.
There's,
there's some significant spikes and uses.
But the problem is it correlates to a significant spike in population in the
state.
Right.
A lot of people moved to Colorado just because of marijuana.
They moved to become a part of the business and because they just wanted to be
free,
you know?
And then California,
we've had medical weed forever.
Now we have legal,
legal weed.
And I don't think it's changed much here.
But you do have,
there's,
there's some,
there's some issues.
There's,
there's definitely,
I mean,
I don't think it's beneficial in any way to sugarcoat the fact that having legal
drugs makes people have more access to those drugs.
Means means maybe there's going to be a few people,
whatever the number is,
who do those drugs,
who wouldn't have had access to them without it?
I thought,
I agree,
but I think it's diminimous.
I think it's like,
I think and the number of people who's going to turn around go like,
you know what?
I want to try it.
It's legal now.
Math,
like dentists doesn't recommend it,
but I feel like I went,
who the fuck's gonna do that?
You say that,
but how many fucking people were on Adderall and the only differences shit,
the doctor's prescribing it to,
it's really good shit.
That's what the president bumps said.
Yeah,
that's what I hear you're saying that.
Do you think he does?
He said we sniffing and he always,
well,
here's the,
I don't think he's on cocaine.
So,
and I always describe to people who don't,
who don't know what this is like.
People on cocaine start one sentence and then finish another.
Right.
But it's like talking to someone on cocaine or the precedent and they just,
but I don't think he's on,
but he's always,
you always hear him with the stuff.
I think he's like bumping addy.
I,
I don't know.
I don't think he's bumping it,
but I think he's definitely,
well,
he might be,
why am I seeking,
to me it's not,
I mean he's,
he's a wild man,
but he's definitely got accusations from his past about use of and fet amines.
There was a,
there was a journalist that actually detailed the very Duane reed pharmacy where
he used to get this prescription diet medication there,
air quotes,
diet medications,
which is fucking speed.
Right?
And look,
the guy has an exorbitant amount of energy.
I mean,
it's quite impressive for a man in his seventies who eats shit.
His Diet doesn't exercise and he's always ready to go.
I mean,
when he was campaigning,
he didn't seem to ever get tired.
He would go and do these campaign events and he would always be talking and it'd
be full of enthusiasm.
We're going to make America great again.
We've got to build that wall higher.
We're going to tell those Chinese,
listen motherfucker like he was.
I mean it's an incredible amount of energy.
God bless him.
He so 70 some odd years old.
It's amazing that you don't have to drug test him.
It's amazing.
You get trace test players,
baseball players.
I was going to say they're the guys we need to and what I mean,
what is that all is
not a performance enhancing drug.
The auto percent talk to journalists.
How many journalists will be totally honest about it.
They are fucking hooked on Adderall and they are very productive with it.
Very productive.
I tried it once.
It's wild.
Somebody gave me some,
I didn't try it.
I just sat there and looked at it and I go,
I don't need that in my life.
I've been scared of coke.
I've never done coke and I'd never done Adderall.
I don't fuck with speed because I can't shut the fuck up already.
My Dad is not for me.
I need something to calms me down.
It makes me feel weird.
I feel like I'd be that guy who like does it.
The first time in my heart explodes out of my chest.
You'd be like scraping the off the roof with a shovel,
you know,
did because you're so high energy.
I was like,
Jesus,
I can't worry that I would love it.
That's what I'm worried.
I'm worried.
I would love it and I'd be like,
okay,
from here on out,
it's all about May.
You know,
we just,
marijuana does the opposite.
To me,
marijuana is like,
well,
we could all be cool together.
You know,
I finally tried pot.
Yeah.
I find finally what happened.
I never,
I never tried it before,
but you know,
I was,
I was actually,
um,
years ago,
I was in Colorado for 20 backstage at a snoop concert.
Oh Geez.
You have to try it.
I didn't have to because I was secondhand stone.
It's like tried it.
It's like,
it's like when I go to church with Coco,
I mean I,
you're just getting into just hot docs.
You know?
I literally was people's church with cocoa for people to understand what we're
saying,
church of what's happening now.
Podcast with Joey Diaz.
I didn't,
I didn't mean that.
I actually went to like a Santa Maria Church shouldn't sacrifice the chicken,
although we have done that in Miami when he's out of Miami,
all bets are off when Joey's down.
But like,
uh,
like I'm in the middle of a story on his podcast and I fucking forgot the ds at
the end of the story.
I literally,
like I told her and I like ended it and then only the next day did I go.
I never told him the end of that story.
I fucking forgot it.
But so someone says a snoop,
snoop wants to meet you.
He's in his dressing room backstage at this concert.
It's like,
Oh fuck yeah,
I'm going to go meet snoop.
Are you kidding?
So I opened the door to this backstage area.
Dude,
I can't see my hand in front of me.
I see my hand in front.
It is foggy.
I like
windshield wipers and my fucking glasses.
I can't see shit.
And I'm,
I'm wandering and I got maybe halfway down the hall and I was like,
I can't,
I can't.
I turned around,
he bolted out the door.
I was like,
you know,
just panting on my hands and knees.
I was like,
I can't do I.
So I couldn't go back until the next year,
like two years later,
I'm back in in Colorado.
But because everybody was making fun of me because I like,
you went to Colorado and didn't smoke though.
Like that's like going to Italy and not eating pasta,
you know?
I was like,
okay,
next time,
next time.
So I go out and I try it and I was like,
all I kept saying was I wish I was drunk.
I wish I was drunk.
I wish I was joking.
I just,
I dunno.
It was like a bad,
I just,
it was so antisocial.
I felt so weird.
I felt so sort of introverted and it was unfortunately in like,
they have this pot smoking church in Denver.
Whoa.
Yeah.
It's like you go and you can just smoke pot and it's literally in this old
church,
they got beautiful paintings on the wall.
It's crazy.
It's trippy,
and so I was there and I tried it and I was like,
how much did you smoke?
Not a lot.
Two heads.
Two,
three.
Yeah,
that's too much.
Is that too much?
You want for lightweight?
If I was your friend,
why am your friend,
but if I was right next to you at the time,
I'd say a little baby hit Billy.
Just a little baby hit.
Don't get crazy.
He's like this.
That's all.
I want this and then let's just relax.
Don't get credit.
Don't take it.
When it comes back around again,
it's too much.
It's too God damn strong today.
It's not what it used to be.
I was in a very recently in Austin,
Texas and Texas still has regular weed.
It's very good weed,
but it's regularly.
Well,
you could smoke it and you're like,
I'm here.
Everything's fine.
California no longer.
These motherfuckers right here,
these little backwoods that Jesus that is not regular wheat that's got a glass
tip and that will put you on the fucking moon.
Brian Cowen had one hit of it last week.
He couldn't drive himself home hours later,
hours later he was still here hanging out.
I'm awake,
I'm awake.
He had to get my friend Brendan had come and get them.
Yeah.
Couldn't try it.
It's awesome.
It's fucking Straw.
There's lots,
some different shit.
So next time I did it,
I did something.
Someone said,
you know what?
Maybe you should try something else.
Sativa versus indigo.
I tried it a second time.
Laugh my ass.
I was with funny friends.
Okay.
And I had a fucking blast.
So I don't know what I did or shouldn't have done or should do or shouldn't do.
But it was I a lot of fun.
Yeah.
Sativa is more,
um,
you're thinking more.
It's a little bit,
you have a little bit more energy.
Endeca crushes you.
You just like,
Oh my God,
I've got to go somewhere and lay down.
I can't handle this.
It's,
but it's different for different people as well.
But I'll tell you that Chick-Filet tastes damn.
Oh,
that's way better,
right?
Hate tastes great.
I got to tell you,
I hate,
hate,
tastes great.
I mean it's my ignorance and hate,
but I see what you're saying.
Thank you.
I had to explain to my kids was closed on Sunday.
They were driving by.
How come?
No one's,
there I go cause it's,
it's the baby Jesus's Day.
Okay.
If you really want to celebrate the baby,
Jesus though is hear me out.
I watch a lot of TBN because I'm a lunatic and I like,
I will always wonder like if the Jews were on television all the time we were on
television going like send this money,
what would they say about us?
But for some reason,
I don't know why Jesus needs a lot of money because they're always on TV telling
you to send your money to Jesus.
Right?
So I'm thinking if you really want to do something for Jesus,
Chick-Filet open on Sunday and donate all of your revenue to Jesus,
to churches,
all the [inaudible] think of the money.
Just the after church crowd alone.
Everybody would flock,
no pun intended,
right to the chick filet and stock up and have all their money.
They can even
have people volunteer to work those days and donate all your money to Jesus
because he apparently needs,
I don't know what he needs with it,
but he needs a lot of money.
Well,
I don't know if the chick filet guys,
the people own it are of the same ilk as the Trinity Broadcast Network folks.
Cause those TBN folks.
I don't think you're being mean by saying they're shysters.
You know,
they're straight.
They're just,
they're just stealing money from people.
I think that Chick-Filet guys like legitimately religious person who really
truly believes that he's saving the world from gay folk marrying each other.
Yeah.
And Stop Bro.
Migraine.
It's not logical,
but they make a goddamn good chicken sandwich.
Gotcha.
Quite quite tasty.
And I telling you I can't.
I think it's more ignorance than hate,
but if it doesn't rhyme,
ignorance tastes great.
But like,
I dunno,
at night they had this lunatic on,
he's on all the time.
They're,
they're paid half hour shows,
but this Peter Popoff guy,
the fucking miracle,
springwater,
the prosperity,
the prosperity preachers talk about a fucking bill of goods,
man.
You know that that Guy Creflo dollar,
his name is fucking Cref.
Like I'm guessing that's not his Christian name,
but it's this,
but it's his evangelical name.
Is craft a donkey made that name up private?
I would hope so.
That was,
that was the dude you tweeted about him years ago.
That was the dude who was out in the world getting donations because he needed
to update or upgrade his g four to a g six and I was like,
Jesus six Christ,
this fucking this guy.
It was going to say I need it cause I need to spread the Gospel and so you need
to give me money so that because my g four just ain't cutting it anymore.
I need to upgrade.
I wish she had gotten a seven 37 Max eight but that's just me.
It's just so amazing that that hustle still works.
The,
the prosperity ones are so gross because they go after people that are so poor
and destitute that they can't pay their bills and they tell them,
if you just send me money,
God will pay you back 10 fold.
And I know what you're saying.
You don't have any money but you do.
You do.
You take that money,
you send it to Jesus and Jesus will bring prosperity in your life.
And then they have all these folks that are giving testimonials about how I was
down on my luck.
I didn't have money for rent,
I didn't have money for food,
but I knew that Jesus needed this money.
So I sent Jesus the money and Jesus paid me back 10 fold and now my life is
filled with joy and prosperity.
Am I being hateful?
And I say that that is what religion preys on the or the no,
I'm searching for answers.
Yeah.
But I think for some people there's like,
I mean this is older,
wiser me,
right?
When I was younger,
I would agree with you 100% but I think at this point I think there's some
benefit to like having community and having this environment where everybody
goes to be humbled and everybody goes to agree that they're going to be good
people that file the ethics of Jesus and he put a little money in the dish and
you know,
they have to keep the operation running and there's a lot,
I think there's a lot of churches that do a lot of good,
but I think for every one or two that do a lot of good,
there's these motherfuckers that are just stealing money and tribe and Rolls
Royces,
just hypocrites.
Giant fucking castles,
you know,
like that Joel,
whatever his name is.
What's that guy's name?
Houston.
That motherfucker.
He owns a shoe.
Huge arena.
He,
they,
they do the show in there and,
and he caught a rash of shit when he didn't let all the hurricane victims stay
in his place.
Yeah.
He was holed up in his $10 million mansion.
That's about days.
It was only 10 million.
You know,
it's not his only property.
he has several houses.
It's just so distorted the,
the,
the whole idea of it all.
So distorted it.
But I think,
I think there's a lot of community churches that do a lot of good where they
provide people with comfort.
I,
you know,
it doesn't necessarily have to make any sense and it doesn't make any sense,
but it provides them with comfort.
I appreciate it.
Like I respect people of faith.
I think it must feel wonderful and I'm know how fields,
but it must be wonderful to believe in something like that.
So devoutly without any evidence,
without any indication or proof whatsoever that what you so firmly believe in is
true.
But it's the hypocrisy of it that I just can't abide by it.
Right?
Like these prosperity guys,
uh,
like the prosperity guys,
like people who used to have a or claim to have some kind of holier than now
moral code that now think like the pimp president's cool.
It's like I get it.
But like your whole thing was like the Bill Clinton was the biggest scumbag in
the world.
Right?
And He needs to be impeached and castrated.
And,
but like,
let's have some consistency.
It's the PA,
Chrissy,
that I can abide by.
What's up some consistency is all,
well,
particularly with Trump,
because Trump was a,
and this is not a knock on him,
but he was a lifelong democrat.
I mean,
he only really became a republican when he thought about running for president.
Yeah.
And he was an independent for a minute,
and he was a Democrat again then he was Republican.
It's a pure hustle.
I mean the,
the glass has been cleaned and squeegeed and you could see right through it.
That's why it works on the evangelicals.
That's what I'm saying.
It's their whole,
he's the pimp Joel Osteen.
Like,
he's like,
that's what it is.
Well,
he found his hustle.
Yeah.
And I don't want to be mean about this,
but I think it's accurate that there's,
there's a level of intellect that just subscribes to that kind of stuff.
That like I had a friend,
she was in the Mormon church for a long time and she left the church,
but she was really honest about it.
She said,
I have a problem that I'm susceptible to bullshit.
Like she suscept because she grew up a fundamentalist.
And so she's susceptible to,
you know,
to like type people,
like a ruse crystals and the,
the lights feeling light.
She's susceptible to all that shit.
And she would recognize her susceptibility,
but she was being really honest about it.
You know,
that she's like,
I have a real problem.
I grew up believing something that doesn't make any sense and I believed it
wholeheartedly.
And she goes,
and that sort of formulated a big part of how I ascertain what is accurate in
the world.
So she's left with,
he's like child likes skills of being able to discern what's bullshit and what's
a hustle.
She's like a little kid.
I have a great amount of respect for people who grow up in a cult and who can
make their way out of it.
I mean,
can you imagine when you're a child,
you're most impressionable and,
and you're steeped in that.
That's all,
you know,
like you don't know that there is an alternate perspective and uh,
and you're able to grow up and say,
oh wait,
there's a whole big world out there.
Maybe I'm not being told the truth.
I'd that's incredibly powerful.
It's really hard I think for it to break with the only thinking that you've ever
known in your life.
I think it's amazing.
It's one of the,
probably one of the hardest things that a grown adult has to do.
So recognize that the paradigm,
this,
this framework,
they've been living their life under his auto utter horse shit.
It's like,
I mean the Mormon want is so crazy too cause it's like the,
the results are great.
The people are so nice.
They're the nicest cult members of all times.
But then you go back and look at the actual framework of the religion itself.
You're like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
He was 14 he like hold on.
Joseph Smith was 14 and 18,
20 when he found golden tablets that contain the loss work of Jesus and only he
could read them cause he had a magic rock.
But like that's Judaism and Catholicism.
It's all there.
All the guys,
he mythological horseshit,
but they know who the guy was like,
I mean,
he's so recent.
Too Real.
It's too well,
that's the thing,
is it?
No,
it's like Scientology.
It's like,
yes.
Well we know it's a lie.
Psychology's even crazy science fiction writer.
Literally,
you failed a failed science picture.
Writeable writer,
terrible failed science fiction writer.
Damn.
Mother fucker never made a second draft in his life and one day said the,
if you want to make real money,
start a religion,
that is his greatest quote.
Yeah.
And they did it and got it.
Some can't knock his hustle.
People want to buy into that.
It's amazing how 2019 it's still rocking some lesson.
I mean,
it is.
Even after all those documentaries,
even after the Leah Remini show,
all these things just,
they go out in the world,
they tell everybody it's horse shit.
And then a brand new Scientology center opens in Miami.
I'm like,
seriously hilly.
We know we are in New Orleans opened.
We already know.
Some people don't know.
The people don't know are never gonna know.
That's what it is.
It's like you're going,
if you know,
if you want to put it in a money to it,
like some people have $100 some people $5 and this is like intellectually.
Some people have a lot of room to work with.
Some people don't.
They just,
their brain doesn't work as good.
Just like some people have poor genetics when it comes to their ability to run
fast.
Some people have really shitty brain development genetics
because obviously you would have sympathy for someone who was taken advantage of
her swinging old,
the official up a con con person.
How much sympathy do you have for the gleefully ignorant or the willfully
ignorant meaning like the information is there.
It's available.
Before I give Scientology my money,
I could just,
I don't know,
Google it.
How much sympathy do you have for like the willfully ignorant people who,
who sort of,
it's,
it's like the fucking dude from my airplane.
They bought their tickets,
they knew what they were getting into.
I say let them crash,
you know,
like,
well,
I'm a big fan of Willie d from the Geto boys and he has a quote that I always
like to use.
You got to let a hoby a Ho.
And I think in that sense,
like you gotta let Dummies get fleeced.
It's just part of,
and part of it is there for us to see.
Part of it is there for you to go,
what?
They gave away all their money.
Ah,
Shit.
Like there's something to that.
That's it.
It benefits us.
Like I'm not a fan of these videos where kids tried to skate board off the side
of a building and they slip and fall and land on their head and everybody's
like,
Oh shit.
But,
but those videos serve a purpose.
And that purpose is not everybody gets to do the hands down on the side of the
building and survive.
Right.
Some people fall in the land on their fucking head and they're never the same
again.
And then they're left with like a third grader's Iq for the rest of their life.
That's real man.
So
George Carlin's bit about,
you know,
the kid who swallows the most marbles doesn't get to grow up and have kids of
his own.
That's how it's supposed to work.
Unfortunately it sucks if it's your kid.
It's all of us are experiencing this life together and there's some folks that
are just,
they're going to do a shitty job of it.
And part of me thinks that because there is no utopia,
right?
There is no enlightened people.
There's no one civilization that's got it all nailed and everybody gets along
together and everyone's totally fine with every single choice everybody makes
cause everybody ever been to a waffle house.
That's a utopia.
It's close depending on how drunk you are.
Because of that,
I think we operate under this,
uh,
this weird system where you've got to see the failures in order to recognize
that failure is possible.
I think there's these actual community benefit to people fucking up and there's
some community benefit to people getting fleeced.
Listen,
I always say that,
first of all,
I don't believe anybody that says any artist or anybody out out in the world
creating something and putting it out there for people to react to it.
I don't believe anyone who says they don't read their reviews.
So their own reviews.
I read all of the reviews and I read the bad ones twice cause that's where you
learn the most.
They could be right,
that could be wrong.
But I feel like you just,
it's where you fuck up that like you,
you learn the most from it.
And,
and I think I feel like as a white man in America all the time,
I have to keep myself in check the way you were describing earlier about how
like you know what,
if you just come to realize that maybe the world isn't exactly the way you
perceive it and that maybe there's a lot of other people who have very different
experiences from the ones that you have.
And so maybe the reality of the world is different for those people and you can
be a more enlightened person by being more empathetic and trying to understand
those perspectives.
Trying to walk a mile in their shoes.
And I just feel like
I've learned so much more from the mistakes that I've made in the failures that
I've had certainly than any of the successes I,
I have in my home.
I have no,
I have movie posters,
but they're like Arthur,
other people's movies,
you know,
I have none of my own movie posters at home.
That's,
that's,
that's at the office.
That's not what home is for.
You know,
except I had one for awhile.
I had one poster of one of my movies that I hung in the bathroom over the toilet
cause it was the,
my least favorite and I just wanted to be reminded every like that,
that was the time I took a shit,
you know,
like for the whole world to see.
And I hung it over.
It's either for a number of years,
it's not there anymore.
But like I just,
I just,
I wanted to remind myself of it.
You know,
you're a smart guy.
You take motivation and failures.
I mean that's what failures are really good for.
When you fail at something,
there's,
there's a benefit to that and that you,
you go,
God that sucked.
I don't ever want to suck again.
Like let me figure out a way to not suck.
Like I always say that with about comics.
Like when we bomb,
that is,
it's a terrible feeling,
but it's the best opportunity for growth because you realize like,
Hey,
I,
I obviously didn't do a good job.
I need to figure out what the fuck I did wrong and battened down the hatches and
get this ship right.
Cause I can't experience that again.
I became a comedy fan in no small part because I had been to shows where I've
seen some of the biggest funniest guys bomb.
And unlike Jesus short of being a soldier or a cop or like a stunt man,
this is one of the most dangerous self-destructive jobs.
Like it's,
it requires such bravery and such strength of soul and thickness of skin that
like I went fucking Vegas,
it's like 2000,
um,
and saw Carlin big beautiful room sat like front row.
It was weird cause like the stage was like a wall.
Like I was sitting against like the fucking stage and I had to look up and like
Carlin shoe would like pass like right in front of my eyes just above my,
my eyeline.
And he was doing material for one of his last specials and it was the one I
think might,
might even the second to last.
He had that whole bit about like he doesn't believe in God,
but like he believes in like shit he can see and he's afraid of like the Saunder
Joe Peshy line,
you know,
that whole bit.
And he was in this big old God fearing crowd there in La and in Las Vegas.
And they were not about this.
They were not about it.
Not One I odor,
not one little bit.
And he's trucking back and forth doing it.
Fucking crickets.
Fucking crickets packed house sold out on the only one laughing in the room,
just me in this giant room and I'm laughing at my ass off and I'm all by myself
and I'm,
I at some point I turned,
I stopped laughing long enough or took a breath to take a drink.
Right.
I don't look down.
And then I looked back up at the stage and Carlin is right there.
He's like hunched over with his head,
like dangling off the stage,
like practice.
And I look up and I'm practically nose to nose with Carlin and he goes,
thank you sir.
And just walks away and keep stalking the set the stage.
And I was like,
oh my God.
And I saw,
I was at the Improv.
Um,
I it Miami when they,
when they had the one at the number of the,
the hard route,
the hard rock,
I guess they're redoing it or whatever,
or fucking places,
death.
I was like,
man,
you know,
they say,
what did they say?
How rocks the floor though?
That's the Hollywood one though.
Yeah.
Hollywood.
The Hollywood Seminole.
Oh yeah,
it was good.
The bad one was Miami,
the Miami and the growth.
That was,
that was rough.
Yeah.
But,
but the,
no,
it was cool.
But then now it's got like,
they bulldoze the whole fucking place.
They're supposed to be remodeling and rebuilding it.
The Seminole hard rock.
Like,
it's like,
I always say,
you know,
what's the saying that like,
um,
uh,
in a casino the house always wins.
I'm like,
these Indian casinos are the only place where like the house never wins.
Cause doesn't matter how much money you lose there.
We still like rape their women and stole their country.
So like the least you could do is like drop a little coin at the Indian casino.
And that's what I would do.
I'd go play.
They,
that was the only place that is the only place they had blackjack,
uh,
in south Florida.
So you can go there and play blackjack,
but they bulldoze the Improv.
And I was there one night,
Gilbert Godfried was there and I was literally the only person laughing,
but like in pain,
like I was in pain laughing and it was just brutal.
And like,
and I've been in these rooms were like these guys and,
and I was just like,
these are the funniest people that I know.
And it's happened time and time again.
And I've been just shows where they killed and I've been to shows where they
died and I was like,
this is amazing.
This is so amazing.
It's like the,
if the fact that anybody gets back on stage after that,
after a night like that is just,
it's remarkable to me.
I have nothing.
I have such respect for that.
I want to say the bomb and is like sucking a thousand Dick's in front of your
mother,
but not really because somewhere out there there's a guy who loves sucking a
dick in front of his mother.
And if you put another 999,
he wouldn't be that sad.
But no one wants a bomb
in front of their mother.
No one wants a bomb period.
It's just terrible.
It's a ruthless experience.
It's,
um,
it's,
it's just a rips you down and in shreds all your self worth,
it makes you feel terrible.
But again,
some of my best growth periods in my career have come after eating shit.
It just,
you spike,
it didn't realize you've go to go,
got to go to work.
You can't be complacent.
And that's one of the things that fuels and motivates me to this day.
I'm terrified of bombing,
so I'll just keep,
it's anything I can use to make me work harder.
I use the six years since I did my shittiest work had been like for me
artistically,
creatively,
uh,
the most productive.
And like I,
I feel finally after 20 years of making documentaries that I might be doing like
my best work,
like,
but it took that fucking long and it took basically almost six years from
totally bombing,
you know,
to,
for me to feel like I,
I hit rock bottom and then have spiked,
you know,
better than better than before.
You've done some documentaries with some dangerous people in them.
You know,
obviously Griselda Blanco is probably one of the most dangerous people on earth
while she was alive.
Um,
and in this,
you also touch on that.
I mean there's a lot of these people are fucking sketchy folks and you're
exposing how stupid their activity.
Where does that,
does that ever creep you out?
If we get nervous,
like,
cause you're making these documentaries mocking these people and you know,
rightly so.
But it's uh,
not cocaine cow was when really marketing is more exposing.
But this one is like openly mocking.
This one's really good man.
It's really funny.
And it comes out March 29th.
Yes,
sir.
Friday.
Yeah.
And uh,
uh,
April 5th on Vod.
Mm.
Yeah.
Well this one's,
this one's tough because this is like a fresh wound from Netflix.
March.
No Vod,
I'm sorry.
Theaters March 29th and Vod,
April fet.
So like Itunes,
Amazon review on your cable box kind of release.
You're going to get into theaters.
I'm starting off with 12 cities on Friday,
the 29th and then,
I mean it's an island.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
At the Lenley Music Hall.
Oh,
three grand.
Um,
and then,
uh,
where else?
I think San Francisco,
Boston,
Miami,
Orlando.
Um,
if there's like 12 cities and that I guess depending on how well it does a,
it's being put out by Greenwich Entertainment who just won the Oscar for free
sell low for best documentary so they know what they're doing and,
and uh,
like I said,
hopefully people will go see it and listen to it.
I hope it's a comedy.
I think it's common.
It's a common,
we tried to make it how was laughing my ass off?
I was doing chin ups and laughing.
I was like,
what the fuck man,
that fucking guy.
The,
the,
the Tanner,
what's his name again?
Porter for sure.
Porter.
That guy.
Like what?
I just imagine if you got one of those guys in your life and he's just stuck in
your life and like,
Shit,
how do I get this fucking guy out of my life?
And the fact that he borrowed money from this guy and then did loan him money
will loan money to this guy.
Yeah.
Porter loaned it to Tony.
Tony borrowed money for a sorter and then didn't pay him.
And that's what caused this whole thing.
It is Alex Rodriguez has gotta be pulling his fucking hair out,
going,
what in the fuck?
And Alex was paying everybody.
So it was the MLB,
I mean everyone was running a muck in Miami like just by hiring private
investigators running people down.
Alex Rodriguez,
actually,
this is an in the documentary,
but,
um,
when these convicted felons stole the stolen documents from Porter Fisher who
had stolen the documents from Tony Bosch,
they set him up in this whole
fucking tanning salon heist where they're like,
hey,
why don't you go in and try this new spray tan color?
It's trumpy and orange goes,
go try it on.
And while he's in the fucking spray tan machine,
they opened his car and steal these documents,
which has had these client lists of all these famous baseball players,
including the highest paid baseball player in the world,
a ride.
And so they steal it and then they turn around and sell these stolen documents
to major league baseball for cash.
Some MLB has this rag tag band of misfits,
these,
this internal FBI like their own internal investigations division that they
created after the balco,
uh,
steroid scandal.
They're running amuck.
They are seducing nurses,
former nurses from Tony Bossis clinics.
They are literally in diners with convicted felons handing over bags of cash
from some MLB slush fund.
I don't imagine that we're going to 10 99 the guy and I don't know where this
cash came from,
125 grand.
And what they did was this,
that the felon who was doing it had a buddy at a neighboring table at this diner
with his cell phone recording video recording this transaction.
And then he turned around and went to Aa rods camp and said,
I'll sell you a video of me selling known stolen documents.
Everybody knew these documents were stolen.
Jan will be buying these tool in records,
stolen evidence and the state of Florida,
Department of Health investigation for cash from a felon.
At some point he gets like freaked out and nervous and he deletes this video off
the hard drive.
He winds up selling a rod,
a blank hard drive for six figures.
Okay.
And a rod sends this hard drive,
he rods,
people send this hard drive around the world to like data recovery services to
try to get this video back.
So unfortunately the felon didn't get his second six figure payment because that
was,
that was the first six figures were against the recovery of the debt.
But he got like two,
300 grand to sell a rod,
a blank hard drive erodes dropping money on private investigators who like
having car chases through South Miami.
Um,
it was just totally crazy and it's like I always say like,
you come down to the swamp and roll around,
you're going to get some mud on you.
So when MLB came down to Miami,
one of the guy,
Jerome Hill,
the,
the former Baltimore cop turned,
uh,
Florida Department of Health investigator.
He,
he says unequivocally that majorly baseballs investigators broke the law in the
state of Florida and should have been prosecuted for it and held accountable for
it and never and never were.
I mean,
it's good to be a multi billion dollar monopoly.
How old was a rod when the scandal broke a rug was definitely towards the end of
his career.
And so that's the interesting thing about,
because let's be real,
I don't give a shit about steroids in baseball.
And this era of steroids in baseball was not the same as the other,
you know,
the Barry bonds,
kind of era of steroids in baseball.
Um,
these were not guys,
you know,
with next the size of my waist or anything like micro dose.
There are micro dosing and it was HGH and testosterone.
And a lot of these guys,
I mean,
listen,
they're,
their,
their livelihoods are contingent upon their physical performance.
Yes.
And so you got to play like,
what is it,
162 games in 180 days.
It's the most physically grueling schedule of any of the,
uh,
of the professional sports.
And guys have always been looking for an edge.
In the 1950s,
the Yankees were going out the Copacabana all fucking night apparently.
Okay.
Here's an Adderall issue with baseball as well.
Absolutely.
A disproportionate number of baseball players compared to the general population
are on Adderall.
That's,
that's why I said it's a performance enhancing drug.
But you had guys like Mickey Mantle and Whitey Ford and Billy Martin partying
all night at the Copa Cabana.
They have to make a 1:00 PM game,
maybe even a double header.
They're doing greenies,
they're doing amphetamines.
It's always been a part of,
of of baseballs finding that edge.
Now you got guys who are just looking to maybe recover a little faster,
you know,
from,
from injuries or fatigue.
You're looking for guys who,
um,
are,
are looking to maintain peak performance for a longer period than,
than their bodies might have otherwise allowed.
Um,
is it that big of a deal?
I Dunno.
It's not,
and it's,
it's,
it's a weird deal.
It's a weird thing that we have an issue with.
Like you've look,
if they did the same sort of stringent testing with NFL players,
you'd find out that everyone's on stones.
That's just a fact.
You don't get people that big and they do catch him every now and then.
But I feel like it's like one of those things where like,
you know how the drug cartels,
they'll let some trug drug shipments get busted so the other ones will get
through.
I almost feel like that's what they do with,
with NFL players to get caught.
Like,
oh look,
we could,
we were testing,
we got somebody to,
that's what,
that's what this was with a rod.
You know,
bud Seelig is the steroid commissioner.
Full Stop.
That's the bottom line.
His tenure was marked by the famous,
you know,
Barry Upon Derby or Mark Warren.
Sammy Sosa.
Absolutely.
So he
knowingly,
I believe,
um,
exploited and profited from that era of baseball that really saves them after 94
players strike.
I mean baseball,
look at the size of those guys where they started.
Yeah.
I mean so many of them,
they literally more familiar documentary.
We morph them from like a,
before an afternoon.
Cause there I think that they turn into fucking baseball monsters,
snacking balls to Guantanamo for Christ.
Hey,
what's interesting to me is as some people recovered from that stuff and some
people did not.
Jose Canseco never recovered.
He never recovered in the public eye does and that's why he's so pissed.
Like that's why the ad,
it's fucked up when you're,
when you're the pioneer in something people really,
and due date they had a street named after him in Miami and they quietly took
that shit down in the middle of the night after decades of naming that street
firm.
He was just totally humiliated and think it's also because he ratted out.
A lot of guys today ride a Rod Leete names to try to distract or diffuse.
But he didn't put out a book.
Yeah,
but like it's the public nature of can't Seikos book.
It's like,
I don't know,
I'm just guessing,
but he's,
his book was like his book turned out to be like the way they can say goes book
about stories turned out to be like the Steele dossier of baseball.
It's like everybody thinks is pissed and thinks is a bunch of bullshit and then
over time it slowly proven true and at the end there's a pee tape.
Yes.
I think that therefore holds well that's,
that is a good way of looking at it too.
Right?
Because like think about the outrage when Clinton got his dick sucked by Monica
Lewinsky and compare it to Donald Trump.
Haven't at least two women that we know about where he paid off the fucked and
people are like,
Eh,
as the evangelicals where those stand and all that,
eh,
let them,
it was before the man found Christ.
That's when a lot of them say,
do you find Christ?
And I was watching a documentary where there was a guy who was,
uh,
some,
some Christian Guy who was saying this,
all of these accusations or before he was born because he was born in the eyes
of Christ when he accepted Christ into his life,
I guess when he's running for president,
decided 20 paid off store me.
Yeah.
But like the night before the,
but after that,
then it became Jesus the after.
So after he left,
oh,
paid off stormy.
Like when,
when did he pick the day before the election.
I feel bad for her too because I feel like she thought like,
this is just going to go all in on this.
And then she lost the court case against him.
So she owes his legal fees.
300 grand.
He was crazy.
Like,
what the fuck is she going to get that and now she's trying to do stand up.
Yeah.
I mean that's a lot.
What I end jobs,
um,
she's on her craft.
She was trying to do standup,
I think.
No she's not.
Yes she is in Houston,
Texas.
They were calling the her the queen of clap back.
I that is lean of the clap.
No,
no,
no.
Clap back.
Oh,
okay.
You know like clap back.
Like she said,
say something bad about her.
She's going to come after you even worst that clap back expression like someone,
Kim Kardashians claps back the critics like,
like that is the dumbest,
I cannot wait for that one to fucking dry up and go away.
Not Kim Kardashians that,
that expression like Twitter,
insult comic kind of Shtick.
Clap back.
They're calling it when someone has something to say about someone saying
something about them that's clapping back.
Right.
But how does that translate to stormy Daniels doing standup?
How can you do stand up out of clap backs?
Well,
they were calling her the queen of clap back that she's going to do stand up
again.
I mean,
who knows?
Maybe she's hilarious.
She's going to take it seriously.
I mean you never fucking know.
I mean,
as a comic I,
I,
I leave the door open for all possibilities,
but being,
it just means to me that she got this situation where she thought she probably
was told by everybody,
look,
hey,
you're going to win this.
He's going to pay you off.
You're going to,
everyone's going to know that you told the truth and people are going to pay for
your interviews and man,
but this is America is broke.
Supply and demand economy.
Like if she could make more money,
standup comedy's hard work.
If she can make more money just spinning on a pole.
Yeah,
but like why?
Cause she's got probably got bad hips.
She's like in her 50s or something.
Isn't Ching?
I don't know.
She's the older lady,
but she's not young man.
You know,
she's not young.
Hell she that she's only 40 oh Jesus.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Stormy.
Don't clap back at me.
I thought she was older,
hard life ideas meal.
As we say in my hard life,
Bro.
It's just,
um,
it's just,
but that thing is that we,
everyone's so used to it now.
It's like not that big a deal.
It's like even if a new accusation came out,
people would be like,
ah,
like,
like do remember the New York Times report about Trump?
We're talking about a shady business dealings and they thought I spent years
rear-ender yeah,
totally didn't do a damn thing in and out just off his shoulder.
It's problematic.
And I'll tell you why.
Um,
it's what I call the,
the new American values.
It's to me what,
what I think screw ball is about in the end.
Meaning like,
yeah,
it's fun and it's funny and it's a forest.
It's a romp.
Uh,
you laugh.
But I think that there's a conversation to be had about what I call the new
American values,
which are lie,
cheat,
and steal and be,
get rich or get ahead.
And these are values that we're teaching our children now,
not honesty,
integrity,
tell the truth.
Do onto others as you'd had done a hunter,
you have the golden rule on,
we're now showing them be a bully,
um,
lie,
cheat and steal.
And you could be the biggest Mo,
uh,
highest paid baseball player of all time,
lie,
cheat and steal.
And you could be the commissioner of Major League Baseball,
lie,
cheat and steal and you two kids can be president of the United States.
And I think this toxic toxicity of the new American values is going to
do damage for generations and we're not going to be able to fully comprehend or
understand or analyze the damage it's done for some,
for some time.
And it was like after Clinton Clinton redefined what sex meant and we were
adults.
You could laugh at it,
but the truth is,
is that he said oral sex wasn't sex.
Right.
Okay.
Um,
and we saw the spike in sexually transmitted diseases among teenagers and young
people,
mostly through oral sex because they said,
oh,
well the president said really?
That absolutely.
Yeah,
that talk about a health.
it was a,
it was a legitimate public health crisis use.
You saw following the Clinton Lewinsky scandal,
you saw an increase in sexually transmitted diseases through oral sex amongst
younger people because the president,
it's hard for us to,
because we see the president right now is sort of a,
a comic,
you know,
as he sorta,
it's,
you know,
he's a reality show president.
We know it's bullshit.
But what do you tell kids?
This is the president of the United States.
Is that what it was or was it because there was so much discussion about him
getting his dick sucked that more people wanted to suck dicks and get their
decks sucked?
I think without question,
obviously the uh,
the size and scale of the coverage,
unquestionably people warming,
well legitimately,
but people,
people for a while,
people thought,
when I say people,
I'm talking to younger people.
Um,
developing mines,
impressionable youths were under the impression that you could not get a
sexually transmitted disease through something that wasn't sex and that and the
president reset those values.
Just like this president,
I feel is re calibrating our values.
And I think that that's,
that's what's most,
I mean other than the potential of nuclear war,
I think,
I think that is what is most dangerous and what could,
could cause the most long term damage from this is these new American values
lie,
cheat and steal.
I was literally at a Q and a with one of the kids that,
the little kid,
Ryan Blanco who plays Tony Bosch in the movie,
the lab coat and the,
the hair.
He's amazing.
He's hilarious.
And so they're all great.
And he said,
I was at a Q and a and I was like,
you know,
what lessons do we learn from this movie?
And He,
this is where I got this from.
He interrupted,
he's 10 years old.
And he's like,
well,
I know,
I know.
I'm like,
Brian,
you have to raise your hand.
It's your Q and a to dude.
You're,
you're on the panel.
And he's like,
lie,
cheat and steal and to win or something like that.
And I was like,
Oh fuck this kid's 10 years old,
you know.
And I'm like,
this is what he thinks.
The values of America.
Well,
it's interesting because in the documentary,
one of the big things,
the news clippings is George Bush discussing steroids in baseball in 2004 was it
2000 state of the Union.
And he was talking about how it sends the wrong message that cheating in
baseball sends the wrong message to the youth of
America.
And there's,
I thought that was silly at the time.
I was like,
Eh,
we'll fucking message.
But the reality is those things do have a ripple effect.
And if you tell people that the way to become this superstar athlete is not just
through hard work and dedication,
but also through taking things that are illegal because they're going to pump
you up and give you an edge on your competitors.
We're a shortcut society.
So we look for those,
those tricks of the trade,
you know,
always.
And we,
and we don't believe necessarily when people do achieve something naturally or
via hard work,
we go,
what did,
what did he do?
What did she do?
What she really do problem is some of those shortcuts work like Adderall,
like steroids.
They fucking work,
man.
You know,
the UFC has had a giant problem with them for a long time and it was exacerbated
by this time period in the early two thousands where they allowed people,
I guess it wasn't quite the early two thousands.
It was actually later in the two thousands where they allowed people to take,
uh,
exogenous testosterone under therapeutic use exemptions.
They would call it TRT.
And so this famous like the Vitor Belfort era when he was on TRT just start
smashing people cause he looked so ridiculous,
he was so jacked and that during that time period they,
they fell into this,
there was a sort of uh,
uh,
really a piss poor way of justifying it.
That justification was these people have low testosterone,
low testosterone is a disease.
If we give them testosterone,
they can perform better.
But the way around that was these guys were actually on steroids.
The steroids crashed.
Their testosterone had go and get a test look my testosterone's low.
Like Yup,
you need testosterone.
And then they would take steroids,
you know,
essentially not steroids but testosterone which has similar effects.
And,
um,
and then eventually the UFC said,
look,
we fucked up.
We're going to go a hundred degrees,
the other hundred and 80 degrees the other way and Higher Usada and we're gonna,
we're gonna crawl up everyone's ass with a microscope.
We're going to find out what the fuck is up.
And men bodies changed.
Careers crumbled.
Bamyan we saw so many people get busted in the beginning.
So many people got caught and still are getting a Tj Dillashaw just got caught.
Who's a bantamweight champion?
Just,
just relinquished his belt for some,
I don't know what he got caught for.
I don't know what the circumstances were.
And some people have been caught for accidental contamination because they're
like,
there's a lot of different supplements that you could buy.
Even creating standard stuff that's totally legal to take,
but they,
they're contaminated because you're buying them from cheap sources.
They make them in China and what have you.
That was the problem with this biogenesis thing is first of all,
Tony Bosch,
who wore a lab coat,
had a stat.
The scopes,
hilarious,
called himself doctor t hat said Doctor Tony Bosch and believes,
which I think I am to have to check my email.
He went to the same medical school is Dr Pepper and Dr Dre.
Well,
I'm a ordained minister just so just so you know,
I've actually married people that's legally illegally ordained minister.
I got it online.
Tony Bosch,
despite having attended one of our interview subjects,
refers to as the belief school of the medical and performing arts to get a
doctorate.
Um,
he was never a licensed physician in the United States and he was yet,
he had legitimate
prescription pads and DEA numbers from doctors that he could then prescribe
these drugs.
And in fact wanted to go one step further like we were talking about with the
pill mills and actually sell them in house to his clients and was buying them in
the black market from some dude in a suburb of Miami,
making the Shit in his garage.
So that's problematic.
Well,
you know,
here's one that's problematic.
That's kind of weird.
Doctors of Chiropractic,
like,
you know,
they don't go to medical school and they,
some of them will check this check if this is true.
Can chiropractors write prescriptions?
I don't think that they can.
I think some of them really,
I think in some places they can write prescriptions.
Is that like in Tennessee or in like,
so
where is that thing says?
No,
says they can't.
Like if some of them could be doctors though,
highly dynamic adjustment year,
right.
You're feeling it.
No,
don't ever,
how about that?
Um,
I went to a chiropractor then them.
Yeah.
I thought they were real until I started reading about how it actually got.
A lot of people aren't there that are chiropractors say I do a lot of good for
people.
I'm sure you do.
There's a lot of good therapies that chiropractors also offer,
so to churches,
but the,
the actual evidence that manipulating people,
especially your neck,
that it does any good at all.
There's none and it actually has killed people.
People have died from having the neck manipulated.
Well,
I,
I felt a lot lighter after the chiropractor by about $400 when I,
it's true,
I mean they do a lot of shit,
cold laser and massage and stuff that does work.
But if you look at the,
you know,
it was invented by a guy who was a magnetic healer who was murdered by his own
son,
his own son,
murdered them,
ran over him with a car,
and then took over the business.
It sounds like a Sondheim musical.
It does crazy.
And it was all in like the 18 hundreds and we've had it for so long that people,
most people didn't look into it and say,
well,
what is this?
What is the science of this?
This guy thought that he could cure everything,
including blindness,
lukemia cancer from adjusting your back.
This was his premise was based on how's it going?
He came from a seance and now there's no more blindness or leukemia or toss
around.
It's amazing.
But there are still chiropractors that buy into that same idea that they can
cure things,
that it's not just you're dealing with pain and if they manipulate you,
they can relieve pain.
Know that they can cure you of certain ailments because of your spine being on
the aligned incorrectly.
They're going to adjust it.
It's popping you just like this.
Just like you do that with your fingers when you crack your knuckles.
That's a,
it's the same thing.
It's like a release of nitrogen or something.
I'm not exactly sure what causes the crime,
but like legitimate.
Yeah,
but I don't see,
did you see anything?
No.
Okay.
Maybe I'm wrong with them being below write prescriptions.
I will tell you that Tony Bosch could not write prescriptions,
but he was doing,
he was doing it in any way or your,
regardless as we sat in my aunt doing it.
Right,
you're on our list when we say we say regardless of Miami because we're,
we're,
you're illiterate.
But,
but I,
I use it here ironically though.
So I just say no,
but I think he might have swiped a pad from his doctor who from his father who
was in legitimate a legitimate topic.
So he was forging his dads.
He had,
he had,
you know,
but they called medical directors.
That's part of these,
the whole anti aging scheme really prospered in the state of Florida as you can
imagine.
And in no small part,
because there's a lot of doctors who from all over the country retire to
Florida,
but they are still medical doctors.
So you have guys like Tony Bosch,
entrepreneurial,
uh,
with an entrepreneurial spirit who want to open up these anti-aging clinics.
And they knew what's called a medical director.
So they go to a legitimate doctor and they say,
hey,
kind of rent us.
We'll put your name on the business,
you'll get a cut of the action.
And they're basically renting out their prescription pad and DEA number so that
guys,
you know,
these other operators who in this case identified themself falsely as doctors
can,
you know,
exploit that,
uh,
that power of the prescription pad.
And so that's what was happening here.
And more problematic.
He started treating high school kids.
Oh No.
And whose parents and baseball coaches had heard about him through word of mouth
and brought these kids to him to get an advantage.
Um,
you know,
we have a big immigrant community obviously in Miami.
We have a lot,
it's a huge baseball community.
People who are smuggled specifically into the country for the purpose of playing
baseball,
uh,
and signing those big guaranteed contracts right out of high school.
And so you have parents and kids and coaches looking for every advantage that
we're going to.
This guy,
um,
you know,
they weren't hearing about him in the high school locker room.
These were coaches and parents who are bringing their parents to,
you might say a guy who they presumed was a real doctor,
but nonetheless looking to cheat,
you know,
to gain the system.
And that's problematic when you have this guy who knows,
he knows he's not a doctor,
but he was a true believer in himself.
He really thought he was helping people.
And listen,
the proof's in the pudding.
This guy could not exploit traditional advertising.
He wasn't doing billboards and TV ads.
He just,
he was strictly word of mouth.
So he had clients who were getting results,
including nearly a hundred cops who are referring their friends to his clinics.
So these parents came to him looking for help,
help for their kids.
Um,
and those kids are our victims.
Yeah.
Well that's for sure.
There's the last thing you want to do to a kid,
especially one that doesn't have any sort of real hormonal ailment,
is to inject exogenous hormones into their body.
It just fucks their brain up for emotions there.
The other entire endocrine system crashes afterwards.
It causes depression,
leads to suicide and a lot of kids and depending what you're doing to them,
you could also be risking their offspring,
potential future offspring.
You could be killing their sperm.
Yeah.
You definitely can.
The disproportionate amount of,
I mean in the steroid use population of um,
autism,
childhood cancer,
just horrible,
horrible things that happened to the children of people who are,
who are on some of these drugs.
I think a lot of the folks that are looking at it in terms of a career in
baseball or in any other sport where they get benefit,
they go,
hey,
this is the price that I have to pay in order to excel at this extraordinary
avenue for financial gain.
Will Tony Bosch was treating Manny Ramirez and when he was in Boston and um,
low testosterone,
you know,
he was getting on in the years and Bosch started treating him,
put them on a protocol as he called it.
Um,
take the,
you know,
x amount of why substance,
et Cetera at this time each day.
Microdosing as you said.
So,
um,
it wouldn't any event that they were randomly tested,
they wouldn't be detected.
I Dunno if that worked or not or he was giving him placebos on certain days.
I don't know what the,
the scheme was,
but Manny starts to come back again.
I don't know if it was psychosomatic or he really was actually performing better
and that's when he got his Dodgers deal.
What was it like a $40 million deal in theoretically thanks in no small part to
this guy who is,
you know,
who was juicing.
Uh,
and that's,
and then Manny gets busted,
pisses dirty after a surprise test before a game because according to Bosh,
he didn't take the micro dose on precisely the instructions,
you know,
that he had given them.
And so pissed dirty and as a result of the,
what you would assume was negative publicity from Manny getting busted and then
connecting it to Tony Bosch in Miami.
That was the word of mouth that got a rods cousin to come to bosh and say,
Hey,
you should meet my cousin.
He's playing this game and tamp,
I'll come up and,
and meet him.
And it turns out that it's Alex Rodriguez.
It's just amazing that someone who made as much money as Alex Rodriguez has
knuckleheads like that,
who can't see the future because of,
if I was his friend,
I'd be like,
hold on,
hold on.
He's already been busted,
dude.
Listen to me.
They're looking at him.
They're watching.
I know.
Nine.
Yeah.
I mean,
while they weren't even,
weren't even,
they don't get,
listen,
baseball is like everything else in American life now,
including politics.
It's the WWE.
Okay.
When Bud Seelig,
the steroid commissioner was on his way out the door,
literally on the eve of retirement.
And he's like,
you know what,
I need to look like I'm doing something about this because I've got a great big
fat astrick by my name in,
you know,
in the record books here,
like all these players do with the steroid era.
I need to look like I did something on my way out the door.
So he calls his second in command,
Rob Manfred and says,
let's do,
let's do something about this.
And they go after the biggest scalp you can in the game,
Alex Rodriguez.
And so when they needed Alex is the heel.
That was the storyline.
Yeah.
Okay.
So they nail Alex.
All right.
Um,
you know,
the Vince Mcmahon of the game,
Bud Sealey goes,
I took care of them.
Retires,
rob Manfred,
who was in charge of this whole botched,
you know,
quasi legal operation investigation biogenesis and an Alex gets the top Gig.
And is now the commissioner of baseball.
And he goes,
you know,
it would be a good storyline.
Now what if I bring a rod and Pete rose back,
his commentators,
oh,
Janie did for like a rod and Pete Rose,
we're working together by the way.
They were damn good.
They may are damn good television dude.
And as commentators,
until Pete rose got in trouble again,
they asked him.
But now you've got rob Manfred who basically put it all on the line and a rod
who put it all on the line fighting each other in this battle of the legacies
with bud Seelig.
Now they're posing with J lo out at nightclubs and stuff because that's the new
storyline.
The story like,
you know,
one day you're the heel,
the next day you're the hero.
He'll here.
It's like whatever,
whatever.
And,
and,
and they're just selling everybody this,
this bill of goods that this is all real.
You know,
you really have a picture that was him with the Minotaur's body center center.
So real,
so this is,
I don't know if this is apocryphal or real.
I know people who have been in the apartment and claim to have seen it.
The problem is is I don't,
I don't know if they're telling the truth or they're like kind of like fueling
the apocryphal tale.
So
I want to believe,
I want to believe no one to pull.
That's the problem.
We all want to believe so.
I mean,
spoiler alert,
we fucking,
we did it.
We put it in there with the little kid's space.
Amazing.
Just select.
Yes you did.
It's hilarious.
The kid who plays a rod is a fucking amazing.
It's the light eyes.
He's amazing is like when these doing,
I don't want to give too much of a way,
but making the funny faces and court,
it's like fucking hilarious.
I mean it's so good.
I was just laughing.
I was like,
this is so ridiculous.
And to know that this is all something that really happened.
I had to tell you,
we've been,
we've been at this making documentaries for like 20 years now almost.
And so this is the most as ridiculous and fucking absurd is this is it is the
most meticulously researched documentary we have ever done.
Why we're dealing with some very powerful litigious yes individuals and
organizations.
So we knew we had to get this a hundred percent right.
Not to mention the way we shot this on set,
on location for 10 days.
We had the playback on the set so we were committed to this dialogue.
Right.
And so we had to make sure we went and obtained transcripts that were never
released publicly of a sworn testimony in the case to be able to cross check
some of the stuff that we were told and we're going to put in the documentary
and we just,
I mean we actually shot at some of the actual locations in Miami where these
real events took place.
The Fountain Will Live at the Fountain Blue Hotel,
you know the nightclub,
the sports grill in south Miami,
the Ritz Carlton Keep Skiing.
We actually took the kids there,
put the facial hair on,
put the fucking cop uniforms on and the pin stripes on and we just filmed them
all over town.
What's funny about about it in Miami,
no one looked twice at us.
No one thought anything of just us running around these little kids with beards
and mustaches and gray hair and the flat coke scene where they're looking for
the blood in the nightclub.
We lost the vial.
I'm like,
what in the fuck and fact that he drew his blood in the bathroom and then lost
the vial like Jesus Christ.
It was so crazy.
I was just watching it like shaking my head like this is all real.
This is how this went down.
That guy was worth how many hundreds of millions of dollars,
how much owe 400 over 400 million was his gross revenue just in baseball and he
just had knuckleheads.
I mean the fact that he was like willing to keep this guy around him.
He grew up in Miami.
That's who you surround yourself with when you,
when you grow up in Miami.
And that scene was,
I mean,
that scene we had like all those kids,
like all the extra kids partying,
shout out to my director of photography,
BG gold.
Nicky did a hell of a job like that was somehow getting complicated.
Shoot.
It's a great documentary,
but all your shit's great.
Thanks.
I'm a big fan of all your stuff,
but this one's particularly silly.
You should come down to Miami.
You should see we're doing,
I'm almost embarrassed to say it.
I just mentioned to you earlier,
we turned cocaine cowboys into a stage play.
Yeah.
You were saying that before we started and I'm like,
why should I,
you should come back.
How can you,
should come,
it's not a musical.
Okay.
She come down and see,
it's called confessions of a cocaine cowboy.
You might remember in the documentary,
um,
there was a Hitman,
Jorge Riviera Allah who he worked for La that ina the godmother Griselda Blanco.
And,
um,
when we first started researching the doc in 2004,
we obtained a seven volume 1300 page deposition that he gave.
And normally in a depo,
you're like the answers like yes,
no,
yes,
I don't remember.
Don't recall.
This was like,
he was a cooperating witness against Griselda in,
in,
in Miami Dade County,
state of Florida was a three capital murder charges.
So three death penalties.
We're talking old sparky cases and the electric chair.
And so he was cooperating witness.
So it read like a monologue.
It read,
like I'm reading it and going on with the new World School of the arts high
school,
which is where I studied theater.
So I was reading a lot of plays and I was like,
Oh shit,
this is,
this would be like a great play.
And 15 years later we turned it into confession of a cocaine,
confessions of a cocaine cowboy.
And you said it's kind of funny.
So
someone described it or if he's right there.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
my producing partner.
Umm,
that's Yancey areas from a formerly spoiler alert.
He's not on the show anymore.
It's character.
Got into some trouble.
A queen of the south on USA.
Um,
he's,
he's brilliant in the show.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
my producing partner,
David Zipkin describes it who,
uh,
coproduce cocaine cowboys and edited,
edited it with me.
He's described it as a cross between cocaine cowboys and my Twitter feed.
That's how he,
that's how he described it.
So like it's a little reverent.
It's obviously a little absurd if you're gonna put kind of cocaine cowboys is a
live theater event.
So we kind of acknowledged the absurdity of it.
Um,
and the Biz,
the surreal exploitation of it.
And you know,
the Guy Michel Housemen,
who's the director of the play at Miami new trauma at the colony theater and
Miami beach on Lincoln road.
He said,
um,
he said,
why are we doing cocaine cowboys for the theater in 2019?
And I was like,
it's a good question cause like it speaks to the relevance of like,
why do this now?
And I said,
well,
if you take away from the documentary,
you take away the drugs and the money.
It's really a story about immigrants,
children and gun violence.
That's what it's about.
And what could be more relevant in the contemporary conversation then
immigration children and gun violence.
And so ultimately,
I wanted to make a story about the Miami of yesterday,
but the America of today,
like I said,
the Miami of today is the America of tomorrow.
So here's a story about Miami in the 1980s,
but it really resembles the America of today.
And so to do that we had to not make it totally fucking depressing and
disturbing.
We injected a lot of humor and a lot of irreverence and intuit,
um,
the woman Zilla Mendoza who plays Griselda Blanco also plays the state attorney.
So she has this dual role as sort of these dueling antagonists against Rivy the
hitman.
And it's just,
uh,
you know,
I was writing it with a friend or in squire,
this great TV writer and does play on play both roles because I felt that they
were flip sides of the same coin.
I think the state attorney is an interesting character.
Different clothes.
Oh yeah.
She changed and it has,
it has different hair and in fact the performances are so different and the
voices are so different than Zillow does.
Some people after the show would be like,
oh my God,
she was amazing.
Zillow was amazing as a,
as a Griselda Blanco who's the actress that plays the state attorney Kathy and
we're like,
oh,
we won't tell them.
Like that's some weird though,
don't.
Last time I heard of that being done effectively was Mars attacks.
The Jack Nicholson played everybody cowboy president of the program.
I liked Barnes attacks.
These real underrated Tim Burton.
Hugely underrated.
Amazing scores that cool.
I Dunno.
Like especially now I feel like it really holds up.
I still go ack ack
talking about Ufo related things.
It was for posterous.
It's just,
I love that movie.
I love it.
I love,
oh my God,
they're crazy.
It's great.
It's holds up man.
You know,
I it like two years ago.
It holds up.
It's,
it's,
it's wonderful.
It really is.
That's interesting though that you chose to use the same woman.
Did you think about that for a while?
Did you have another woman you always wanted to do it from the beginning?
Always.
I just,
I have a strange relationship with the state attorney in Miami Dade County.
She's been the state attorney for about 26 years now.
And,
and you know,
when she was first elected,
she was like the first,
uh,
Cuban state attorney in the state of Florida.
Um,
very ambitious.
She was,
she's been the only state attorney we've had since Janet Reno left us for the
Clinton administration.
Whoa.
That's how long she's been state attorney.
So now she has one of those records where you examine it and you say,
okay,
what's actually happening in this town?
When people say to me like,
why is Miami so fucking corrupt and why?
You know,
why,
why does corruption grow,
grow,
get a greater and wider than fucking oranges in,
in Miami?
And the reason is when you have the top cop and town is not effectively in force
public corruption laws and does not pursue public corruption.
You have an area where it's just,
you send a message of impunity.
That's the bottom line.
You know,
no trouble arresting innocent young black kids on drug charges or whatever.
But like when it comes to enforcing public corruption,
she's just nonexistent.
And so what happens is,
is you,
you have a,
and of course it,
it's like the broken windows theory of crime.
If you allow petty corruption to,
to,
to go.
Eventually some of these politicians wind up literally in a closet at city hall
accepting bags full of money.
And the only thing we've been able to rely on to some extent is the feds coming
in and trying to help.
But you have the state attorney who as never in her 26 years in office charged a
police officer for non-duty killing.
Whoa.
Despite a proliferation of these incidents.
So it's not like it's,
oh,
it's not happening as often the incidents have exploded in the reason the
incidents have exploded is because police know that they'll get away with it
because Kathy will not prosecute them.
So the message that's being sent is it dangerous,
wanted it,
and it is created a toxic effect with the relationship between obviously police
and,
and the citizens that they're supposed to be protecting and serving.
And it's,
it's created a very dangerous situation,
uh,
in the city.
And,
and it's also created a situation where just like mayor after mayor just gets
away with pure fuckery,
you know?
Oh God.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's what,
it's a not a sexy answer.
People,
it was like,
why is Miami so corrupted by people want some sort of sexy answer?
And I say,
well,
when the top cop is the same person for 26 years,
you know,
if you're looking at,
if you want to know what's wrong in a community or with anything,
you don't look at what changes.
I mean,
mayors come and go,
police chiefs come and go,
commissioners come and go.
Um,
killers come and go.
You know,
criminals come and go.
You look at the constants.
You say,
what's been the same here for 26 years?
That's got to be the problem.
And sure as shit.
That's,
that's the problem.
So I wanted to make a statement about the state of Miami today.
Um,
and say that,
that,
you know,
uh,
also Griselda Blanco was born in Colombia in a very difficult time in the
history of that country during labial Lencia.
This brutal civil is brutal civil war between liberal and conservative parties.
That went on for like 20 years,
almost caused,
caused the horrific murders of like 200,000 people.
Um,
some very brutal,
some very public.
It's been reported that she as a hobby with their friends and their youth,
he's just run around and just bury bodies that were just lying in the street or
lying around.
Like that was just a hobby,
something for the kids to do.
And so you grow up in that environment were saying earlier,
like,
you're opening a cult.
You grow up in that environment.
You're,
it's like he's fucked.
You know,
you're not exactly born into money or power or wealth.
your dad's not a judge.
You don't exactly have those benefits or opportunities.
And if you can try to make something of yourself.
I mean the problem of course as a result of the Blanco went into a and elicit
and illicit trade,
but a trade that a lot of people in Columbia we're getting into from that era.
Um,
it's just,
I wanted to have a discussion about a lot of the characters argue with each
other and the play about how different everybody is.
It's like that and how Miami is like game of Thrones and paradise with slightly
fewer dragons.
You know,
like we just self segregate and it becomes this battle of fiefdoms and,
and um,
cause we're not like,
we're not multicultural.
We're very much segregated.
Like I always say the common misconception about Miami is that we're a melting
pot.
We are not a melting pot.
We are a TV dinner where sometimes the PS fall into the mashed potatoes.
We have our little kingdoms,
you know,
by,
by flag,
by nationality.
Very much so.
Um,
and so everybody's arguing about how we're different and the place sort of when
you walk away you're like,
okay,
but this is a conversation about how we're all the same and some of us have
different opportunities than,
than,
than others.
And it's just a matter of what we're able to make of those,
of those opportunities.
And that was sort of the comparison I was making by,
because it's a little locally,
it's a little scandalous.
The fact that the same actress plays both of these,
these very powerful,
because Cathy,
the state attorney is a very powerful popular figure.
So because you've publicly stated that there's a reason,
there's parallels between her and Chris on the problem and let's say the
portrayal is not the most flattering in the play I word.
I think she gets a fair shake in the play,
but,
but really the character through his commentary comes down pretty hard on her.
I've been publicly very critical of her.
Uh,
I think it had hope in a constructive way publicly in,
in via social media.
Um,
and,
but I mean 26 years in age,
almost 70 people that,
yeah,
that is fascinating.
You got to wonder if it's a spoken agreement or if this is just a unknown sort
of,
uh,
just this is just how she does business.
You don't have to worry,
I call it a conspiracy of convenience because not every conspiracy involves a
bunch of,
you know,
a rogues gallery at a board room table and a dark smokey room.
You know,
it's talking about,
okay,
how are we going to conspire?
I'm going to going to see conspiracies of convenience or just like,
people are in positions of power and everybody just kind of wink,
wink,
nod,
nod.
Everybody knows what they're supposed to do and you don't ruffle feathers and
you don't,
you don't fuck with conventional wisdom.
And uh,
this is the way,
it's all always,
this is the way it's always been done.
So this is the way we do it.
And everybody just kind of,
you either fall in line or they get rid of you one way or another.
And so that's just the way fiefdoms operate.
Oh,
this sounds like such an exhausting project to create a play out of that sort of
horrific time in Miami's history.
It was fucking exhausting.
How could I,
I was like,
when you told me you were doing it,
that's the first thing I thought of.
Well,
being a lazy fuck.
I'm like,
that's so much time.
You know,
it seems like so much time to do and I want to do that.
there's,
it's like documentary racket is not very profitable.
So I wanted to go with a real money is theater plays a playwright,
you're gonna make it fortune Billy.
And I said to him,
to my,
my coauthor or in Squire and the director,
I was like,
listen,
this has to be purely theatrical experience to,
nope,
no projections,
no archive.
Like news footage,
like we using the document.
I'm like,
if in Miami,
first of all these days,
if I just got to put my pants on to leave the house,
that's a fucking hassle.
Meaning like if I could just,
when I'm home,
if I can just chill,
I want to just chill.
So if I'm going to be like,
okay,
I gotta go see a fucking play,
I'm like,
so first thing I had to do is put my pants on.
All right,
so I put my pants on.
Then you've got to get in the car.
He got a brave,
this traffic it's spring break on right now might be beach.
It's out of control.
So you've got to go to south beach,
go to the theater Lincoln Road and then like pay your hard earned money to see
this play because plays are more expensive tickets for plays or a lot pricier
than a movie.
Right?
And so,
or a Netflix subscription.
So you go and I'm like,
I don't want people to be there.
Like what the hell?
I could have just stayed home and watched the shit on,
on Netflix.
I want people to go like Holy Shit.
And we're actually seeing that.
We're seeing,
um,
a really disproportionate number of people coming to the theater who have never
been to like a live play before because of their interest in the subject matter.
The title,
confessions of a cocaine cowboy or the documentary.
So people are coming and they're rowdy and they're like interacting with the
actors.
It's kind of fun cause we do a lot of breaking of the fourth wall where Rivy
talks to the crowd or the cops talked to the crowd.
And so they're talking back the audience in there and it's fun and very and
funny and,
and uh,
I think pretty thought provoking,
particularly at the end.
And,
um,
they just like,
uh,
this audience is,
is we're like,
oh shit,
you can't duplicate this experience in any way.
You know that and be like,
yeah,
I mean,
watching comedy on Netflix is one thing.
Being in the room,
it's a totally different energy to the terminology.
It's a rush.
It's like,
you know,
it's like a drug.
How many seats?
Uh,
this,
the or 420.
Oh,
it's great for 20,
bro.
Fairly intimate.
Oh,
but that's a good size for an intimate live show.
It's huge.
And,
and um,
it's a beautiful,
it's like a historic theater in Miami beach.
There's not a lot of,
what's it called?
Which the colony theater.
Okay.
I know where that on Lincoln road.
It's that walking street.
You're probably getting back when we had the comedy festival,
you probably did it where you are at the Fillmore and you might've done the
colony Jackie Gleason show more now.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
I've done,
I've done a few different places.
I don't remember all of them.
This is a smaller room for you,
but like it's a great cool space.
It used to be an old movie theater and my grandma used to go see,
we don't preserve a lot of our history in Miami.
It's like I was saying earlier,
like we're such a young city,
literally young and we're like America's perpetual rebellious teenager where
like everything new we don't like,
we have a transient population,
a lack of institutional memory.
And we're like,
fuck history,
let's just knock this down and build new.
Cause that's the only way to create jobs.
Like knocking shit down,
redesigning it,
rebuilding it,
repopulating it,
building a tall,
or creating more revenue because we don't have a state income tax in Florida.
So it's just like,
it just constant hustle.
So to have a place like that where it's like,
oh,
we're going to take a deep breath and say this is a cool spot.
There's no venues like this in town.
It's been your for almost a hundred years.
Like let's preserve it,
you know,
let's preserve the original architecture.
Let's preserve some of the,
the,
the oldest,
like this old carving of like Pelicans,
like this really creepy like old school deco art.
They just preserved it and it's really,
it's like the perfect environment to do a show that's like by Miami.
For Miami.
Yeah.
The no income tax things very attractive to people.
People,
millions to states that don't have income.
That's one thing that pulls Nevada,
pulls people into Nevada.
Why do you think Oj Simpson moved there?
He had like,
there was a law where they couldn't get his money.
Right.
We have the homestead,
uh,
law,
like the,
you know,
you can,
you can't get the money,
you can't get the house you can.
It's a,
it's a great place to sort of hide assets.
I told you like a third world country.
It's got banana republic.
Yeah.
Cause he,
he got,
he lost the civil case.
You're 30 plus million dollar judgment against him.
And so we bought a fucking house in Florida.
Now he,
is he still there?
Oh,
I don't think so.
I think he's in Vegas now.
I think he,
they released him but they were gonna I think he might be on paper.
So I think he might have to stick around.
I'm not certain because if for a while he wanted,
I think he was asking permission to go to Florida when he first got released and
the Attorney General Florida was like,
no thanks.
To be fair though,
she was a blonde woman,
so she was scared.
Uh,
so too soon.
What?
No,
too soon with them.
It's a,
he's,
he's one of the weirdest cases in all of American pop culture history.
I mean he is one of the weirdest cases.
You know,
there's a fantastic photo that someone made a meme of,
of Howard Cosell with Bruce Jenner on one side,
and then Oj Simpson on his other side,
and Howard Cosell say,
and I've seen the future,
you're not going to fucking believe this
because it is so god damn crazy that one of the most famous and beloved people
forget before that murdered,
be loved.
I mean,
he was like the rock.
Oh,
absolutely.
Right.
In that,
and a lot of ways,
maybe even,
I don't want to say more below the rocks,
pretty beloved,
but that level,
I mean,
endorsements,
Hertz,
rental car ads.
He was in movies.
He was loved him.
Beloved personality,
Gun trilogy,
you know,
and,
and uh,
and well,
it was inevitable.
He would wind up in Florida of course.
But,
but like,
um,
crazy,
just crazy.
And this is something that in the end,
not to spoil it,
you've been so,
so kind to not spoil,
screwball.
Uh,
but in the end,
that's also part of the message is the idea that and why we use the children.
These athletes are heroes to these kids.
They look up to them.
These are supposedly role models and how many professional athletes do you know
who you'd be like,
I want my kids to idolize this,
this person.
Like legitimately like legitimately very few.
Sure.
So it's like that's the,
and that's where that whole sort of like lie,
cheat,
steal to get ahead.
Message I think is what's what we're teaching our children these days.
And,
and that's the case with like Oj Simpson.
It's like this key.
People idolize that guy.
So did they retire?
Did a rod retire?
Did he ever come back from this?
I don't know anything about base for one season he did for one season,
he came back,
he got the largest suspension in the history of the game,
but they reduced it,
right?
They reduced it,
but it remained the largest.
So how misspent James or was it a year?
He was like 160 it was almost like a,
basically a full season.
And the following season he came back,
played about another year if from where he was injured for a while.
I think you actually,
you might have been injured the following year and then came back the year after
and then he retired and the Yankees made him like,
they gave them like a fun office job where he would mentor.
Young players really can't make this shit up.
Didn't really,
yeah that is so interesting that he didn't become persona non grata like Jose
Canseco did.
Right.
It's,
I don't know how quite how to explain it and listen,
it's been one of the greatest,
I think reputation rebuilders not even rebuild.
I remember he was hated Nike Spans used to boo the guy.
He was not a beloved figure as a baseball player.
Now he's like,
maybe my mom knows who he is.
I mean she calls him jail,
his boyfriend,
but she knows the bottom line is she knows like he,
this,
I mean I think they're going to be studying this case study of like image Rehab
is going to be studied for like decades to come and like PR classes calculated.
I think it was a lot of it was accidental but,
but like look at,
he's never even apologized or really admitted what he did.
He never went on like the mayor Kulpa tour.
Like Lance Armstrong,
Lance Armstrong is positive.
No,
he never failed a test time.
Yeah.
See that's part of it.
He was on this shady doctors dockets.
How the fuck did the doctor use the right name?
That's,
that's what's so crazy.
Like why did you use his name?
What do you mean?
Why did you use a Rodriguez?
How about use a pseudonym?
Well,
if you remember,
Tony was doing a lot of cocaine at the time and he was like,
he was like in s in a fucking spiral.
His whole life was know he was about to hit rock bottom while he was running
this business.
And what's funny is to his medical records,
there was some file folders,
but a lot of them were in composition books,
like just old school cvs.
Like,
like do you use to the movies that,
so that's why that's the,
I cannot keep wrote in and he would scribble it.
And so those were beings.
But he'd write patient nicknames and dose and then some of it would just be like
stream of consciousness,
like middle school girl,
like journal.
Like he would write his name and different fonts.
He would come up with different like business ideas and plans and,
and make signs,
you know,
for like his businesses and,
and talk about motivational speaking ideas that he had.
And it was like,
it's a real journey into,
into his mind if a cocaine addicted fake doctor in Miami,
which is an interesting journey,
I gotta tell Ya.
Um,
but like he,
uh,
so these composition books on some pages there'd be like code names.
Like,
um,
you know,
uh,
he had a guy that was like,
you know,
that he would name after cars are named after you like me hoe or little Spanish
words or,
or things like that.
Um,
he had,
uh,
a player when he bought,
he bought him like,
Hey,
you bought him an SUV of some kind.
So he like,
you know,
code named them like Tahoe or whatever the fucking car was,
another one was Dui because he had just gotten a Dui.
So that was like,
but then like after a while he just kind of abandoned it and then was like a
Rodriguez or Alex Rodriguez,
by the way,
there's a shit ton of Alex Rodriguez is in Miami.
But when you start seeing a rod in the books,
kind of kind of a tale,
you know,
a little bit,
Jesus Christ,
he's just got sloppy,
you know,
like fucking drug addicts.
What does that can I do now?
Um,
well he's five,
five years off,
uh,
off of cocaine,
which is good.
He went to federal prison and rightfully so for the kids,
for the high school kids that he,
uh,
that he had when the,
when the judge sentenced him specifically said,
you know,
it's one thing consenting adults to engage in this behavior.
It's another thing for you to drag kids into this mess,
Aman and potentially poison them.
Um,
so he went to federal prison,
get this,
he winds up in a camp.
So it's like minimum security federal prison in Alabama.
And he winds up teaching in part a,
a nutrition class to his fellow inmates.
He's in there with Jeff Skilling of Enron who's teaching a business class to his
fellow mates and Jesse Jackson Jr who's teaching a political science and civics
course to their fellow inmates.
They say prisons,
the best place to to learn and that cabin.
So we actually,
so one of my,
you know,
we were running out of money on this movie and so as you always do with movies
and,
and so there's a couple of scenes that we wanted to do that we ran out,
we just couldn't do,
we had to cut them from the schedule.
So one of them was an epilogue with all the kids in federal prison,
like jumpsuits and like Tony Teaching and like a little baby,
Jesse Jackson Jr a little baby Jeff Skilling from Enron,
a little baby.
And another thing,
another thing Bosch was doing is he was like,
you see him at the beginning of the movie sitting at the bar at the Ritz Carlton
and key Biscayne and he's writing little protocols on a fucking cocktail Napkin
for the bartenders on how to build muscle,
how to lose weight.
So he was doing that in prison for inmates for like vitamins and supplements
that they could buy in the commissary.
He would like,
he'd be like,
hey Yo,
Dr t,
I want to,
I'm trying to build muscle mass and be like,
okay,
here,
here's the program.
Go to the commissary by these vitamins and these sublet and there you take it
this time that Yo Tony,
I'm looking to lose weight.
What do I do?
And you give them,
and then doors started coming to him like,
Hey,
I'm looking at,
my wife wants to lose some weight or weight.
Yeah.
He'd give him protocols.
Wow.
Yeah.
So I mean,
he's very,
I told you he's very much a true believer in himself.
Um,
he's got a lot of faith in himself and he for a while was planning on opening a
nutritional supplement business across the street from Marlins Park in my Miami
posts or billion.
Like this is pretty recently.
It hasn't happened yet,
but like he's looking around for new,
for new opportunity.
And Miami is a,
is a land of,
of,
of new opportunity.
I told you this last time,
I saw you that it's an old saying that I love that La is where you go and you
want to be somebody.
New York is where you go when you are somebody and Miami's where you go and you
want to be somebody else.
It's just,
it's not only a town of reinvention,
it's like,
it just always been a sunny place for shady people.
I just always wanted to know what happens to a fake doctor who gets both selling
steroids to kids.
What does that guy do for a living afterwards?
I think now he's,
I suspect now he's just sort of being,
you know,
uh,
a subsidized by family and friends right now.
He does have kids and child support.
Probably it to make some how,
I don't know exactly what he's up to.
I'll,
I'll ask him the next time I'm gonna see him this weekend.
It's a Q A's ghost towns.
Oh yeah,
he does.
And he's quite squared funny.
He's quite a sobering.
Um,
well I think you still drinks,
but he doesn't,
he doesn't do,
uh,
Carlos it trucks anymore.
Yeah.
And that was,
uh,
that was,
that was bad for awhile.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
that's always the,
uh,
the bad decision making route.
What's,
what's funny about this is that he,
so we caught him like on his way into federal prison originally.
So in November of 2013,
Alex was in the midst of the arbitration that you see at the end of that,
we portray at the end of the movie in Mol MLBs offices in Manhattan and we get a
call from his publicist and his publicist says,
Yo were,
Alex is on a break from the arbitration and he's coming down to Miami.
He's got an office in coral gables,
which is just like very wealthy,
affluent suburb.
I'm adjacent to the city of Miami and it's actually the city where the
University of Miami's located,
where Alex Rodriguez field is at UNM on campus.
And so they said,
listen,
Alex would like to meet with you to talk about possibly doing some kind of tell
all documentary,
Jeez,
this is November,
2013.
So I'm like,
yes,
please.
Yeah.
So I figured like this is a hush hush meeting.
You know we're going to do this on the,
at his office in Coral Gables,
they say meet us some day,
high noon at Hillstone restaurant,
which is the power lunch spot in that neighborhood.
The most prominent corner in the city,
Florida ceiling windows,
open kitchen.
Everybody from the street to the dishwasher can see everything going on in that
dining room.
They want to meet us there at noon.
So I'm like Oh okay we go there,
slammed every seat taken.
Mob scene around the host stand three,
four deep at the bar.
They a scored us down the center.
Me and my producer Alford Spellman right down the center aisle parade us
practically and you know ESPN and the 30 for 30 [inaudible].
They really fetishized the directors.
So like they have like video interviews with us like you know in bumpers like
every hour,
like little little segments.
And so people sometimes recognize me,
usually in Miami,
like close to you em.
Cause we did the u m you know doc.
So if there's any play,
any place I was going to be recognized.
It was two miles from the University of Miami.
And so the tickets right down the middle and they're in the center booth on this
elevated platform around the back is Alex Rodriguez holding court.
And we literally,
so we literally have to like step up on stage to join him and like all eyes are
on us in this place and I don't know what to do.
We kind of get introduced and I,
I need like an icebreaker.
So I'm like,
so who's going to call page six?
You are us.
Sure.
Shit.
Two weeks later it was in page six.
And so we sit there and um,
Alex didn't laugh.
The publicists laugh.
That's like a publicist joke,
you know?
I guess so.
Um,
because it was clear that we were there to be seen having this meeting.
It was so clear.
Why do you think they did the,
it was,
it was part of Alex's when you said,
was there a plan?
There was kind of a plan.
It was part of Alex's,
like up PR offensive or push back against major league baseball.
And so,
um,
we sat there with him for almost an hour and a half and he just lied,
just lied to us on the whole time.
And I didn't know that a lot of about everything.
I never met Tony Bosch.
This is all,
but you look at my records,
I,
you know,
my performance didn't improve after the time he claims to have been treating me.
I'm not a baseball fan on my cue.
To me the,
I call it screen saver.
All right.
I just,
but my producing partner Alfred is a degenerate baseball fan.
He gets to look the fucking mlb.com package has it on his desk,
on his iPad all day long during the season.
I'm just like,
I mean I guess he does that instead of Ambien.
You know,
it's like less sleep eating with baseball I guess.
I Dunno.
So he's just like,
but he's a huge baseball fan and when I left I was like,
he made a lot of good points.
Alex did off.
It's like fucking lied about everything and I can't blame him.
He lied to everybody in those days.
I mean,
he was in a,
he was desperately trying to salvage his,
his career and his legacy and he,
he,
he allegedly lied to the DEA in a queen for a day meeting.
Who the fuck lies in a queen for a day meeting other than George Papadopoulos.
I mean,
you're split.
The whole point is you're supposed to tell the truth that they're not gonna
gonna fuck with you.
Um,
but,
but he allegedly did that.
So it was a queen for a day meeting.
So Queen for a day,
meeting with the feds,
you get a letter for it.
They're like,
we're investigating w you're a witness in an investigation.
We understand you may have participated in some illegality or committed some
crimes in the course of this larger investigation,
but we're not after you.
We just want you to come in,
feel comfortable and free to tell the truth to our investigators so that we can
pursue our investigation accurately and fairly.
And we will not,
whatever,
anything you say will not be held against you essentially in a court of law.
So you're queen for a day,
they call it,
you get a letter or queen for a day letter and the hawks,
they call it queen for a day.
And so I don't,
that's the thing the feds have.
And so Alex was free to just speak.
The only thing you can do is lie to a federal agent that is a crime.
And that is in fact,
I think with George Papadopoulos was ultimately he lied in his queen for a day
meeting.
The whole point of a queen for a day meeting is to test,
to not lie and not cause you can't get in trouble essentially for any crimes
that you admit they are about the investigation.
So that was the allegation is that he actually lied.
So I listen,
I'm a documentarian.
People lie to me for a living.
Um,
I'm fine with that.
Especially because they spelled my name right and page six and that shit was in
bold.
I don't have the juice to make that happen.
Alex is,
Alex is publicists to have the juice to make,
to make that happen.
I was flattered that they,
you know,
write about me,
but like,
um,
but you didn't think that he was lying.
I suspected he wasn't telling us the whole truth,
but I thought he made some interesting points in Alpha to Alfred had was a
pitcher in high school,
North Miami Beach,
senior high go chargers and Alfred had actually pitched against Alex Rodriguez.
It's like one of his only more stories from his baseball years in high school,
right,
is that Alex was a senior at the Alpha,
was going to some sort of Ron Frasier,
a baseball camp,
had a u m and they did this summer league game and Alfred,
this is my eyes are glazing over and telling the story.
But like Alfred Alfred's pitches against a ride and who was already a senior
already a beast.
Everybody knew this guy was gonna was gonna go in the draft and be huge.
Everybody knew about that.
He had been the talk of the high school baseball community in Miami forever.
And so Alfred pitched against him and he held a rod to a triple.
Of course Alec,
you know,
a red smack,
the shit out of this ball sailed away.
But he,
he was,
it was only a triple,
it wasn't,
it was a rare,
not home run for Alex.
So I thought,
oh,
we have like a funny personal anecdote.
Like we can find some common ground here,
right?
You're talking to someone who might be a potential interview subject,
you know?
And so I'm like,
actually Alex,
you and Alfred have met before Alpha rolls his eyes.
Like he's going to embarrass me until this dumb shit story.
So I tell out like,
isn't this funny like you guys,
but,
and Alfred held you to a triple and he kind of looked at me like,
you're looking at me right now.
He's just,
he was totally on amused and maybe looked even a little hurt or offended.
Oh Wow.
This is the greatest baseball,
one of the greatest baseball players of all time,
the highest paid baseball player in history.
And here I'm just telling this cute story from like 20 years earlier whenever.
And he seemed like he held me to a triple.
I'm like,
how could you be upset about that?
You're one of the greatest of all time,
like super winners.
But it's like,
yeah,
it's,
that's why I left.
I was like,
this guy's a really interesting character.
Like he's a complicated guy.
He's an interesting guy.
He's a sensitive guy.
Like I was curious about him.
I was excited about the prospect of interviewing him and man,
they practically ghosted us out.
Yeah.
The January of 2014,
that's when they lowered,
they reduce the suspension.
I started hitting up every month.
I started hitting up the publicist yo following up on that meeting,
because it's funny,
in the page six article it mentioned he met with the 30 for 30 filmmakers,
Billy Corbin outfits,
Spellman.
Uh,
he's been shopping a book proposal to these publishers.
The book proposal thing was total bunk.
Literally not true.
The,
the publishers were like,
we'd love to get one,
but we haven't gotten a book proposal from a Rod.
He really did have the meeting with us,
but like,
so everything was just,
we were just kind of pawns in his game,
which is cool.
Whatever they respond to.
This documentary?
Not exactly,
but I,
for like six or seven months,
I'm emailing with the publicist and then it was clear that they weren't
interested.
So,
and that became the tactic,
by the way,
when you said was there a strategy,
the strategy was to shut the fuck up and just like,
like you said,
like with the president,
Big New York Times as big [inaudible] Expo Day.
And then maybe if we just tomorrow in this 24 hour news cycle in this fucking,
in this world of just being us being hammered with bad news,
you know,
in 240 characters,
every nanosecond of every day,
just shit just passes.
And they just,
they,
they played it just so,
so beautifully and brilliantly.
And then almost a year later,
we got a call from a friend of Tony Bosch.
You guys want to meet with 20 bucks?
She wants to talk to you about doing a documentary.
Like,
hell yeah.
So we take the meeting,
really interesting guy when would meet with them several times over several
months.
And then he says,
listen,
I want to do this interview goes,
I'm getting sentenced to prison tomorrow.
And we knew about that,
you know,
that the case was ongoing.
Um,
he said,
but look,
I expect the judge will give me 45 to 60 days to surrender to complete this drug
rehab program I'm in.
And then I'm only going to get like a year and a half,
two years in prison.
And so we could find a couple of days before I have to surrender to do this
interview and these,
and I'm like,
dude,
listen,
let's see what happens tomorrow.
I'll think depending on how much time the judge gives you,
like you're going to prison one way or another,
like maybe you want to spend some time with your kids,
get your affairs in order.
Let's make a decision tomorrow whether or not we're going to take two,
three,
four days out of your life for this,
maybe we'll do it.
When you get out into an,
you know,
in a year and a half years,
federal,
you do at least 80% of your time,
but then you go to halfway house.
Sometimes for a little bit at the end of six months or as long as a year.
So he goes,
he goes to court,
the judge says four years and you have not 45 to 60 days to surrender,
but 45 to 60 minutes to surrender.
Give me your,
you know,
take off your belt and your shoe laces and surrender to a,
to the bop.
And he did.
And so the backburner it again.
And then I got to fucking email from Tim.
Al Frank,
who was the Woodward and Bernstein of the case,
he's the,
the journalist who got the stolen records from Porter Fisher,
the whistle blower and blew the lid off the whole thing.
At the beginning of 2013 he says to me,
Porter Fisher called me and he's asking me for your number to discuss,
possibly doing a documentary with you.
And I was like,
first of all,
like
we sometimes don't make documentaries about things that we make documentaries
about things that happened like 2030 40 years ago.
This felt like it hadn't ripened yet.
Like it was still a fresh wound.
You know,
like people wouldn't be willing to talk,
like you have to kind of wait for more time to pass,
you know,
and here we are and I'm not a spiritual guy and I don't really believe in the
universe talking to me or anything,
but I thought,
man,
if ever someone was trying to tell us something,
it was like,
you got to make this documentary.
The three primary players in this major baseball scandal all independently of
each other,
contacted us within just over a year to talk about doing a documentary about at
night Alfred Jokes,
uh,
that um,
in Florida when you get out of prison,
uh,
your first call is to your mother,
your second calls to rack and toured,
who?
Our company,
you know,
to see the talk,
a documentary.
And Tony got out,
I hit up Tony,
I'm like,
I'll come visit you in Alabama.
How much time did you have to do?
And you wound up getting a sentence reduction.
He did just about two years.
And then he was in that camp in Alabama.
I wrote him,
I said,
dude,
I'm going to come up and visit you.
And had talked about this.
He said,
I'll be in a halfway house in six months,
so let's just meet in Miami.
I was like done.
And then when you meet porter and you meet Tony and you see them,
their interviews and the documentary,
you realize like,
well Alex,
this isn't even about Alex.
You know,
it was like,
this is about these guys in this crazy,
you know,
Carl Hiaasen s like Cohen brothers botched robbery like story.
And so like that was the story we wanted to tell and that was the Tony Porter
part of the story.
We'll listen dude.
You fucking nailed it.
It's a great documentary or really enjoyed it.
Like I really enjoy all of them and uh,
just keep on fucking knock it out of the park,
man.
Thank you.
A baseball metaphor.
I appreciate that.
Really appreciate it man.
Thanks for having me Joe.
Uh,
give everybody your social media.
Tell people how to get ahold of him.
Billy Corbin,
I'm not the lead singer of smashing.
Same on Twitter and on Instagram and Billy Corbin Instagram.
Same on Twitter.
Hit me up.
Beautiful.
Thanks brother.
Thank you.